LET'S CALL THIS MEETING.
OF THE SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE. TO ORDER.
AND WHY DON'T WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM THIS IS QUITE A USUAL.
GEM OF A MOMENT WHERE WE START
THE MEETING WITH A QUORUM.
YEAH THAT'S FANTASTIC SO -- TAKE
A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HERE [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
STONE I CASKEY.
OKAY BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE AN
OFTEN NOW LET'S ON WHAT WHEN WE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT COUNTER WE GIVE US SOME
NUMBER GARCIA RECALLING.
HI SO THE THE THE CONSENT
COUNTERS MOVED BY CENTER WILL
CASKEY [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
GONNA.
HELP CAME IN LATE.
AND SIX PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SEN ITEMS NUMBER THREE FOUR
SEVEN NINE TEN AND TWELVE ALLEN.
HI ALLEN HI BATES ALL RIGHT
BATES AYE HILL.
I LIKE S. SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
STONE BY CASKEY.
HI OKAY SO THE VERY WE CASKEY
MOVED CONSENT CALENDAR -- HAS
BEEN APPROVAL WE WILL WE WILL
ALLOW OTHERS TO ADD ON AND WE
HAVE A SERVER GARCIA APPARENTLY
IS.
RUSHING HERE AS WE SPEAK.
YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE BEFORE WE GET
STARTED -- MUCH BETTER LAST YEAR --
LET ME TAKE A QUICK MOMENT I
HAVE TO SAY THAT -- WE WE HAVE
HAD AN EXTRAORDINARY STAFFER ON
ON THIS COMMITTEE.
FOR THE LAST COUPLE YEARS DAVID
GARCIA WHO IS.
LEADING US.
AND GOING OFF INTO THE
REGULATORY WORLD HE WILL DO LEAD
TO FAIRS -- AND YOU KNOW WE WE
ARE JUST INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL TO
YOU DAVID FOR ALL THE WORK YOU
DID FOR THIS COMMITTEE YOU KNOW
YOU'VE YOU'VE JUST.
YOU HAD A JUST A GREAT SENSE OF
THE POLICY WRITTEN GREAT
ANALYSES YOU ALSO HAVE THE THE
BEST -- TIE TYING SKILLS IN THE
BUILDING AND YOU NEVER EVER EVER
NOTICE THAT HE TIES TIE
DIFFERENT WAY EVERY DAY.
HI IT'S REALLY REALLY SOMETHING
THAT AS JUST GOES BEYOND
ANYTHING I COULD EVER HANDLE --
SO DAVID I DO WHAT YOU WANNA YOU
WANNA TELL US ABOUT YOUR YOUR
PLANS AND AND AND YOU KNOW GIVE
US A VALEDICTORY SPEECH.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING IS GOING
TERRIBLY WRONG WHEN A STAFFERS
SPEAKING DURING HEARINGS -- I'LL
JUST SAY THAT I'M I'M OFF TO THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD I'LL BE
THERE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
STARTING FRIDAY I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON ALL OF THESE ISSUES
AND SO I'M SURE I WILL SEE ALL
OF THE SAME PEOPLE AGAIN JUST IN
A DIFFERENT CAPACITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DONE OKAY SO WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL YOU DAVID YOU'VE BEEN
SICK OF BEING A PUBLIC SERVANT
YOU CAN CONTINUE IN THEIR PUBLIC
SERVICE -- AT THE AT THE AIRPORT
AND AND WE'RE JUST VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DONE SOME.
BIG ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR DAVID
GARCIA.
ALRIGHT -- WHEN WE ALLOWED
CENTER STONE TO ADD ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR?
SINCE WE'RE HERE ENOUGH.
AND SO THE SECOND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THAT'S IN CALENDAR ITEMS NUMBER.
THREE FOUR SEVEN NINE TEN TWELVE
SKINNER AND STERN.
STONE STONE HI OKAY THAT'S ONE
MORE VOTE FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IT'S MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION OKAY SO WE ARE.
WAITING FOR SUMMER GARCIA WHO IS
ON HIS WAY APPARENTLY. TO CALL
OBERNOLTE.
TO MISTER CHAIR.
YEAH.
RIGHT [inaudible]
WE CAMPUS [inaudible]
BOB SAYS [inaudible]
THE RIGOR [inaudible]
JERRY.
READ THE BOSSES -- THE YES.
LEAVING US TO THE AIRPORT.
IN A MORE OFF TO THE AIRPORT AND
THERE.
ARE.
WE WILL FIND OUT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES
.
WELL THAT'S WHAT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YESTERDAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
HOW WOULD YOU JERRY -- SENIOR
FIRST BILL FOR THE SENATE.
A HIGH -- NOBLE PLEASE BE
ADVISED MEMBERS.
PLEASE BE ADVISED ANY HAS.
TO YEAH.
ALL RIGHT SO WE WELCOME YOU HERE
WE ARE APPRECIATIVE YOU BEING
HERE -- WE TURN IN YOUR IN YOUR
PACKETS THAT -- ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT THIS IS AB TWELVE FIFTY
TWO AN ACT RELATED TO
ENVIRONMENT AS A SMALL GRANT
PROGRAM.
MEASURES IS A GREAT TO BE HERE.
AT TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF --
GOOD MORNING INTO MY NEW
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE -- AND
IT'S ASSEMBLY BILL -- TWELVE
FIFTY TWO IS LEGISLATION LATE TO
CAL EPA ADMINISTERED SMALL GRANT
PROGRAM IN SO CURRENTLY CAL EPA --
THEY PROVIDE GRANTS.
TO THE COMMITTEE BASED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO HELP ADDRESS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES.
AND THESE ISSUES IN AREAS THAT --
ARE JUST REPORTS IMPACTED BY
ENVIRONMENTAL -- ISSUES -- AND
SO THESE GRANT -- PRO THIS THIS
THIS SMALL GRANT PROGRAM THESE
PAYMENTS THE MAXIMUM WARDS I
BELIEVE IN THE NOW STATED IS
ABOUT A MAX AMOUNT OF THE FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THEIR WARDED UPON THE COMPLETION
OF PROGRAM WORK.
AND THERE ARE -- THERE THERE
AWARD AS REIMBURSEMENTS -- UPON
THE COMPLETION OF THESE PROJECTS
AND FORCE THE SMALL
ORGANIZATIONS.
AREN'T ALWAYS ABLE.
TO TO PUT UP THESE INITIAL COSTS
OF THE PROGRAM AND ARE DETERRED
FROM FROM -- APPLYING -- FOR
THIS FUNDING IN THE FIRST PLACE
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO
IS WE GIVE CAL EPA THE AUTHORITY
TO PROVIDE ADVANCE PAYMENTS.
AT TWO GRANT RECIPIENTS -- AND
IT WOULD THUS.
PROVIDE THEM WITH THAT THESE
FUNDS UP FRONT -- AND YOU KNOW
THIS BILL WOULD RELIEVE THE
FINANCIAL PRESSURE OF SMALLER
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND
ALLOW MORE GROUPS.
TO PARTICIPATE AND UNDERTAKE
THIS VERY IMPORTANT WORK IN THE
SMALLER AREAS IN A LOT OF THE
AREAS THAT I REPRESENTED
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
NUMBER -- EIGHTY THIRTY SORRY.
I HAVE A BIT OF A STAMMERS A
SOMETIMES THEY SAY SOMETIMES
THEY CAN'T.
SO AB TWELVE FIFTY TWO IS A COST
NEUTRAL MEASURE IT EMPOWERS
ORGANIZATIONS TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY AND ENCOURAGES OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND THIS IS THIS -- COMMUNITY --
DRIVEN APPROACH THAT WOULD
IMPROVE ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE AND
GLOBAL WARMING ISSUES -- AND
HELP REDUCE EXPOSURE -- TO THIS
POLLUTION THAT A FAX -- YOU KNOW.
OUR COUNTY CITIES.
THANK CENTER THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE IT -- LET'S SEE HERE
FOR MANY FOLKS WANT TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NO ONE YES ARE YOU ARE YOU'RE.
OKAY FANTASTIC GREAT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS -- MY
NAME IS MY DEALER RETRO FROM
CALIFORNIA RELIEVE -- CALIFORNIA
RELIEF IS A NETWORK.
ORGANIZATION AWARD A HUNDRED
NONPROFITS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WORKING TO PROMOTE.
URBAN FORESTRY INTERMINGLING ANY --
AS AN ORGANIZATION WITH OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE.
MANAGING GRANT HONEST RATIONS --
TWO SMALLER NGOS WORKING INCOME
AND COMMUNITIES WITH THE MOST
NEED -- WE ARE SPONSORING A. B. --
TWELVE FIFTY TWO BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT.
IT IS FOR SOME COMMUNITIES BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO RAISE THE FUNDS
TO IMPLEMENT -- PROJECTS BEFORE
THEY ARE REIMBURSED -- NOT NGOS
WORKING AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES NEED EVENTS PAYMENTS
BECAUSE THEY NEED FINISH OF
CAPITAL TO START THEIR PROJECTS
SOME ORGANIZATIONS DON'T HAVE
THE LARGE.
BUDGET OR THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO START PROJECTS SO
THEY RELY ON CREDIT CARDS -- AND
BANK LOANS.
OF THIS -- PROGRAM WILL HOLD
COMMUNITIES RECEIVE TRAINING ON
TO ADVANCE TO ATTACK AND
MEDICAID. TO CLIMATE CHANGE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARDS AS AN EXAMPLE.
LAST YEAR HE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
SAID HA PROVIDED TRAINING TO
COMMUNITY LEADERS OF COLORS FROM.
FROM THE BAY AREA VENTURA.
LOS ANGELES ON HOW TO STOP LISH
AND ADVANCED GREEN ZONES TO
REDUCE PUBLIC. TO REDUCE
POLLUTION AND IMPROVE LOCAL LAND
USE PLANNING.
AND WITH THAT THEY PROVIDED A
TOOL KIT -- AND SEVEN DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES LANGUAGES -- FROM
ENGLISH TO SPANISH AND MULTIPLE
ASIAN DIALECTS -- SINCE THE
INTENT OF THAT CALIBER HEY.
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GRANT
PROGRAM IS TO BUILD CAPACITY
AMONG SMALLER.
AYE NGOS CALIFORNIA RELIEF AT
LEAST THAT.
ENSURING CALPE AID CAN UTILIZE
ADVANCE PAYMENTS AS A TOOL IS
ESSENTIAL.
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- OTHER
FOLKS ONE ADDED SUPPORT OF THE
BILL CAN COME.
UP TO MY FRONT. FOR COMMON THE
OFFICER CORPS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M.
SORRY MORNING AND OF US BECAUSE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ROOM
TO JUSTICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY ANYONE WHO WANTS TO RAISE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S ANY
RACE REPETITION.
OKAY THE MATTERS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS --
FOR THE SUMMER'S FIRST SENATE
BILL.
I'M A SOME MEMBER AS SORRY
SENATOR WE CASKEY.
YEAH -- THE BILL CALLS FOR A
SPENDING OF THIS ADVANCE MONEY
WITHIN EIGHT MONTHS WHAT'S THE
MAGIC OF EIGHT MONTHS.
THIS SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES THAT
IF YOU GET 50% AWARDED SHALL BE
SPENT WITHIN EIGHT MONTHS UPON
RECEIPT.
AND JUST WONDERING.
WHAT'S THE MAGIC WHY WHY THAT.
I WOULD BE ABLE TO TELL YOU WHY
SAYS A MONTHS COM YOU KNOW I YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT WE
ANTICIPATE IS -- YOU KNOW --
THAT WORK WOULD YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY BE AT THE POINT OF THE
COMPLETION WITHIN EIGHT MONTHS --
AND SO BUT WHY SPECIFICALLY A
MONTH I CAN YOU KNOW I CAN.
THROUGH THE CHAIR SECOND
QUESTION IS IS.
YOUR ADVOCATE HAS WORKED WITH
THE HUNDRED NONPROFITS IT SEEMS
TO ME WITH THE WORK THAT I'VE
DONE ON A LEASE WITH THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM THERE'S TWO TYPES
OF THESE.
NONPROFIT ADVOCACY GROUPS ONE
THAT'S ESTABLISHED IN ONCE HAS A
PROGRAM AND WANTS.
TO GET OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY
AND DO EDUCATION AND THE OTHER
IS THE ONE THAT'S JUST BEING
ESTABLISHES ORGANICALLY GETS
ESTABLISH ONE PART OF THE STAFF
REPORT TALKS ABOUT IT.
A GROUP IN TULARE TWENTY ONE
MEMBERS OF THE TASK FORCE.
AND I'M I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
IS THIS YOUR DOES THE ADVOCACY
GROUP DO YOU HAVE A TEMPLATE
THAT ASSIST THESE PEOPLE YEAH
BECAUSE JUST THIS ONE NUMBER
TWENTY ONE MEMBERS ARE TASK
FORCE SEEMS.
RATHER AND WE'LL LEAVE FOR THE
FIRST TIME OUT OF THE GATE FOR
NONPROFIT IS SAND JUSTIN IS
THERE SOME TEMPLATE THAT YOU CAN.
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE USING IT FOR
ADVANCING THESE FUNDS.
FOR GROUPS TO DO LESS ORGANIZING
OF THE OF THE COSTS AND MORE THE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE WITH THE
PUBLIC WHICH IS WHAT I THINK WE
WANT IT WITH THE SMALL GRANTS.
YES AND THAT'S ALL OUTLINED IN
THE GRAND GUIDELINES HE
PROCEDURES THAT COUNTY PA HAS
DEVELOPED FOR THE PROGRAM SO.
YEAH. FOR THE QUESTIONS THAT'S
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I HAVE IS THIS SOME
INTERCONNECTING.
I WOULD MUCH OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE DECEMBER I JUST --
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OKAY SO THE MATTER HAS
BEEN MOVED BY CINEMA CASKEY AND
ONCE AGAIN CENTER HILL FAILED TO
GET THERE -- WHY DON'T WE -- OF
THIS ACT OF ITS COLOR.
AND NUMBER.
ONE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB FIFTEEN
I'M SORRY.
TWELVE FIFTY TWO AT THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALLEN
RIGHT ALLEN I BATES.
RIGHT BATES AYE HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
STONE I'M SAYING STERN.
STONE.
MY CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
OKAY THE MATTER HAS ENOUGH BOTH
TOGETHER WILL LEAVE THE ROAD
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS ADD ON I
WANT YOU GO AHEAD AND PRESENT
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN THAT'S AB.
SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT SO HAPPY TO
MISTER CHAIR -- SO.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY TWENTY EIGHT
IS LEGISLATION RELATED TO OUR
STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AND THE RELATIVELY NEW BUREAU OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN SO AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW LAST YEAR
ATTORNEY GENERAL HOBBY ERR.
THAT THIS ERA THE STAFF WAS THE
BUREAU OF ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
WITHIN THE THE THE DOJ.
AND HE DID SO TO BEST LEVERAGE
THE DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO MAKE
SURE.
TO PEOPLE AND OUR COMMUNITIES --
AND PEOPLE AND TO THE
COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE THAT
INDOOR A DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE
OF ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION AND
PUBLIC HEALTH HAZARDS.
AS AS A PREVIOUS ANALYSIS OF
THIS BILL STATED TOO FREQUENTLY
CALIFORNIA'S LOWER INCOME.
THE COMMUNITIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR EXPERIENCE
FAR GREATER IMPACTS FROM
POLLUTION TOXIC.
CONTAMINATION AND THE EFFECTS OF
GLOBAL WARMING MORE SO THAN
WEALTHIER MORE FLUENT AREAS OF
OUR STATE.
DOES THESE CALIFORNIANS HAVE
BEEN.
THE D. DENIED A KEY ROLE OR A
VOICE IN THE DECISIONS THAT
AFFECT THE QUALITY OF THEIR
LIVES.
AND SO AS A RESULT THIS BILL.
AB SIXTEEN POINT THREE DOES TWO
THINGS FIRST IT WOULD ADD TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE DOJ'S
BUREAU VINYL JUSTICE TO THE LIST
OF AGENCIES THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
OF PLANNING RESEARCH MISS
COURTNEY WITH REGARDING
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE PROGRAMS AND SECOND THE
BILL WOULD STRENGTHEN THE
DEFINITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. TO MORE CLOSELY ALIGNED
WITH THE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S [inaudible]
THE THEIR THEIR DEFINITION OF
I'M A JUSTICE TO SURE THAT
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
OCCURS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY IT
SENDS A CLEAR MESSAGE THAT
IMPACTED THE COMMUNITY THAT
THESE PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO BE
NOTIFIED AND INCLUDED WHEN IT
COMES TO LOCAL PLANNING -- THE
DECISIONS -- THAT MAY AFFECT
THEIR HEALTH AND THEIR
LIVELIHOOD.
AND SO CERTAINLY -- EXCITED OF
TO TO WORK WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ON THIS ISSUE AS IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT FOR NOT ONLY THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT BUT FOR YOU
KNOW THE ENTIRE STATE.
SO WITH THAT YOU KNOW WE I I I I
WILL ALLOW THE AYE SPONSORS TO
DO THIS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THAT MY NAME IS JASIM
JOHNSON I'M WITH PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
AS THE LAND USE AND HEALTH
PROGRAM ASSOCIATE AT PS ARE AWAY
I EXAMINE THE CRITICAL ROLE IN
THAT LAND USE AND PLANNING PLAY
IN THE HEALTH.
SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS ARE REQUIRED
COORDINATION BETWEEN OPR AS WELL
AS OVERSIGHT AGENCIES AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE WILL
FURTHER STRENGTHEN POLICIES PUT
IN PLACE. TO UPLIFTING PROTECT
OVERBURDEN ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES.
EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY THE BUREAU
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE WILL BE
ABLE TO REMOVE THE INSTANCES OF
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE WHERE IT'S
NOT BEEN PROPERLY ADDRESSED SUCH
AS THE MANY INSTANCES OF
INCOMPATIBLE LAND USE AND SOUTH
SOUTHEAST AND EAST LOS ANGELES.
ADDITIONALLY AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT BY FORMALLY ESTABLISHING
THE DIS BUREAU UMBRELLA JUSTICE
ENSURES THERE'S GOING TO BE A
PERMANENT BODY IN PLACE IMPROVE
ENFORCEMENT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
LAWS ON BEHALF OF YOU TO
COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN
PLACES WHERE THEY LITTLE
RESOURCES OR LITTLE INTEREST IN
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT OR EVEN
REGULATORY FAILURE SUCH IS THE
CASE WITH THE WITH THE BATTERY
RECYCLING FACILITY IN SOUTHEAST
LOS ANGELES.
WHERE THOUSANDS OF HOMES ARE
POISONED BY MILLIONS OF POUNDS
OF LET -- LASTLY BUT OF GREAT
IMPORTANCE IMPORTANCE SEES ME IS
THE BILL'S EXPANSION OF THE
DEFINITION OF OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE INCLUDE MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENT.
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
COMMITTEES OF COLOR IN
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES --
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY BEAR THE
BURDEN OF POLLUTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL NEGLECT BUT THEY
OFTEN LACK THE RESOURCES -- TO
BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY TRULY ENGAGE
IN THESE PROCESSES THAT WILL
HELP.
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES -- THESE
RESIDENTS ARE ALREADY OVER
BURDENED BY ALL THE OTHER SOCIAL
JUST VERY DISPARITIES AND THEY
HAVE TO FIGHT TO SIMPLY HAVE
INPUT ON ACTUALLY HAS -- SO HE'S
MOVING INTO THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
MOREOVER IN BERLIN JUSTICE HAS
STRONG ROOTS IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT YEAH IT'S BEEN CARTED
OFF AND STIFLED BY HARMFUL
INDUSTRIES AND OTHERS WHO HAVE
LITTLE INTEREST IN THE WELL
BEING OF THE COMMUNITY.
COMMON IS PRECISELY THE
HISTORICAL LACK OF COMMUNICATION
ABOUT THIS PLACE IS COMMUNITIES
IN THIS IN THESE CONDITIONS THAT
THERE CONTINUES LEAN DORY.
SO ESSENTIALLY ENVIRONMENT
JUSTICE WITHOUT COMMUNICATION IS
NOT JUSTICE.
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS IS
LEADERSHIP AND IN PRIORITIZING
PROACTIVELY ADDRESSING A PRIMAL
INJUSTICE AND ENSURING CLEAN
SAFE AND HEALTHY NEIGHBORHOODS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU.
I AM MORNING AGAIN OF US BECAUSE
AGAIN WITH THE CALVARY ROOM TO
SLANTS PRODUCTS ON SPONSOR THE
BILL INITIAL ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED SO IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS I'M HERE
TO ANSWER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER FOLKS ONE AT AND IN
SUPPORT OF BILL.
YEAH [inaudible]
SIERRA CLUB. FOR CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHELSEA TO THE CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY AND THE ENVIRONMENT --
PRIMARILY WORKING WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES IN THE SOUTHERN SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I ANYONE ELSE IN ONE ONE RAISE
CONCERNS OPPOSITION.
OKAY THE MATTER IS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
MR TERMINUS I'M CAN I HAVE SOME
CLARIFICATION ON WHAT YOU
BELIEVE CONS CONSULTING IS
VERSUS COORDINATING BECAUSE THE
CURRENT LAW.
YOUR IS A PLANNING AGENCY THEY
COORDINATE WITH NATURAL
RESOURCES IN THE AIRPORT WHEN
THEY'RE IMPLEMENTING PLANNING A
PLANNING DOCUMENT.
AND WE HAVE AN AMBITIOUS PROGRAM
FOR THEM AND CLIMB AN ADAPTATION
AND CLIMATE -- RESILIENCY FOR
THEM TO DO WHEN YOU WHEN WE'RE
ASKING THEM TO CONSULT WITH AN
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY WITH THE THAT
THE PART EIJI NORMALLY YOU DON'T
CALL DHEA UNLESS YOU'RE READY TO
SUE.
THERE THERE THERE ARE LAWYER SO
NEW WHEN WE HAVE CONSULTING WHAT.
IS THE EXPECTATION.
SO IS FOR US TO IS REALLY HAVING
ABILITY FOR OPR AND ALSO WHEN
NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCY IN
OFFICE OF A SEEK HELP YOU TO BE
ABLE TO COORDINATE.
ON EITHER POSSIBLE CASES ARE
HAPPEN AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
ALSO ASSISTING A LOT OF MORMONS
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES ARE PROBABLY
REALLY WORKING WITH -- PR
SPECIFICALLY AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE
WORKING WITH SB ONE THOUSAND
FERMENTATION WHICH IS A MOMENT
TO JUST AS I'M GENERAL PLAN.
ELEMENT THAT'S HAPPENING SO IF
THERE'S ANY -- ISSUES ARE
HAPPENING LOCALLY THAT REALLY
NEEDS TO BRING THEIR
ENVIRONMENTS JUSTICE BUREAU INTO
THE PICTURE THAN THIS IS A
NATION COR NATION AND NEED TO
HAPPEN.
AND A LOT OF TIMES ARE A LOT OF
ROOM TO STORE DISEASE STORE
REALLY KNOW THAT SAID FROM SUCH
AS THIS BUREAU IN THE AG'S
OFFICE GIVEN THAT'S A FAIRLY NEW
BRO HAS ESTABLISHED ABOUT TWO
YEARS AGO.
SO REALLY GETTING THAT
INFORMATION OUT THERE TO
COMMUNITIES GIVEN THAT WILL BE
OUR HAS BEEN.
REALLY MORE OF A INTENTIONAL
PARTNER GIVEN THE THE DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT INTERACTIONS AND
DIFFERENT RESPONSIBILITIES AT
THE DEPARTMENT HAS CURRENTLY HOT
SO IT'S REALLY MORE FOR US IS
HOW DO WE GET THE WORD OUT THERE
TO A LOT OF COMMUNITIES ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THEIR
SITTING COUNTIES ON DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS BUT ALSO IS HOW DO WE
GET THEM REMOVED AS UNIT TO
REALLY -- IF THEY'RE SEEING
SOMETHING THAT AFFECTS OP OURS
WORK HOW DO THEY ACTUALLY START
REALLY WORKING WITH EACH OTHER.
YEAH BUT SO THAT WOULD BE A
MISTAKE CHAIR SO THAT'S WHAT.
A HAND OFF AS IS IF I THINK I
HEARD YOU RIGHT IT WOULD BE THAT
IF IF OPR IS OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY THEY'RE DOING UP.
OF RESILIENCY PLAN AND THEY'VE
COORDINATE WITH THAT THE E. J.
COMMUNITY AND IF THE THEY WILL
LET THE THE BUREAU NO THAT THAT
THEY'RE DOING AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND THEN IF THEY FOR
HERE OF SOMETHING OTHER HERE.
OF SOME POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS
THAT'S NOT OURS WORK THEY'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO DO THAT BUT THEY
WOULD CONSULTED THE BRING --
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN EXACTLY
SO WANTED THINGS EXAMPLES SB ONE
THOUSAND SO WHEN AND IMPLEMENT
EIGHT AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ELEMENT IS
NOT DONE.
INTO THE TO THE LONG -- THERE'S
NO REALLY ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
OTHER THAN THE AG'S OFFICE SO
THIS IS WHERE THE AG'S UNIT WILL
ACTUALLY COMMENT AND PROVIDE
SOME GUIDANCE IN THEIR HUSBAND
RESPOND EXAMPLES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY FRESNO-AND ON THE INLAND EMPIRE WHERE
THEY ACTUALLY PROVIDING GUIDANCE
TO THIS LOCAL CITY AND COUNTIES
TO BE.
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE ELEMENT --
AND ALSO PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
MORE GUIDELINES ON LIKE THIS IS
HOW INTENT OF THE LAW THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE SPECIFIC A CITY
OF HOW YOU ACTUALLY SHOULD
IMPLEMENT THE ELEMENT.
OF GIVEN THE WE DON'T HAVE AN
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY SPECIFICALLY
FOR THIS -- RIGHT WITH HER PERCY.
RIGHT BUT BUT NORMALLY WE DON'T
WANT LAWYERS MARKING UP THE
PLANNING PROCESS I'M A LAWYER SO
I CAN SAY THAT SO.
NORMALLY IF YOU IF YOU SEE THAT.
IF THERE'S A PROBLEM IF THERE'S
A PROBLEM WHEN THEY SEE THAT
THERE'S A VIOLATION OR SOMEBODY
IN THE COMMUNITY COMES BEFORE
THEM AND YOU KNOW BECAUSE AGAIN
OPR SIGNED INTO THE ENFORCEMENT
IS A WHITE.
SO I GET THAT IF THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE CONSULTING BUT YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES I GUESS I WANT TO
BE SURE THAT IT'S NOT.
THEY DEVELOP A PLAN OF FOR
CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND THEN THEY
NEED TO CHECK OFF FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ON IT WHO
KNOWS NOTHING ABOUT.
RESILIENCY THEY MAY KNOW
SOMETHING ABOUT THE ENFORCEMENT
OF THE LAW BECAUSE THEIR LAWYERS
ARE SUPPOSED THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE FEELING YEAH IT'S
NOT A CHECK OFFICE MORE THE THE
GUIDANCE RATE IT'S IS
INTERPRETING THE LAW SO IT'S NOT
REALLY THAT CHECKING OFF THE
BOXES REALLY HEY HOW.
DO WE INTERPRET THIS LAW WHEN
YOU HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES LOCAL LEVELS
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH HER A LOT OF ROOM IT'S JUST
WE'RE DECISIONS ARE PROBABLY
BRINGING A LOT OF THE LAWSUIT.
AND FOR THE REALLY NEED A LITTLE
BIT MORE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WE
NEED TO HAVE AN EXAMPLE OF WHERE
THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE DOES THAT
IN ANY OTHER.
AREA OF THE LAW BUT THEY WOULD
COME IN BEFORE NORMALLY YOU
BREAK THE LAW YOU BRING IN THAT
BRING AND LAWYERS RIGHT YOU
DON'T BEFORE YOU'VE DONE
ANYTHING AND YOU JUST PLANNING.
I LOVE THE TO THE DPA NEVER
HEARD OF IN THE AIRPORT YOU KNOW
NORMALLY WE SAY WE SET UP THE
PROGRAM WE ENGAGE THE COMMUNITY
WE COME UP WITH THAT.
RESILIENCY PLAN WHATEVER THAT
MAY BE AT OPR TO SUSTAINABLE
CITIES AND ALL THE THINGS THAT
THEY'RE WORKING AT I JUST.
YOU'RE ASKING FOR HIS SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES FROM OTHER DPARTMENTS
ARE JUST KIND OF OKAY I MEAN I
SEE THAT THE AG'S ASK FOR THIS
AND I THINK THAT I SEE THAT
THERE'S SOME VALUE AND BRING HIM
IN.
I DON'T WANT IT TO BE TOO HEAVY
HANDED WHERE YOU KNOW WE'RE
ASKING THE AG WE'RE GOING
THROUGH THE PLANNING PROCESS
EVERY LITTLE THING THAT'S GOING
ON SO THAT'S MY CONCERN I MEAN
I'M.
WILLING TO MOVE THE BILL FORWARD
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANTED.
TO RAISE THOSE CONCERNS.
AND UP INTO AND IF I MAY BE SURE
YOU KNOW I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS I THINK HE VALLEY
CONCERNS I MEAN HAVING.
JUST ESTABLISH THE BILL OF
ENVIRONMENT JUST AS I BELIEVE IT
WAS IMPLEMENTED IN ORDER
ESTABLISHMENT FEBRUARY OF LAST
YEAR OF OF OF OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
I THINK ADDING THE BUREAU NO YOU
KNOW THOUGHT PROCESS IS ADDING
THE BE -- TO THE LIST OF OF OF
OF AGENCIES AT OPR MUST CONSULT
WITH WILL HAVE A BENEFIT IN THE
LONG TERM MEAN WHEN THE WEATHER
IMMEDIATE ROLE IS AT THAT TABLE
IN THE A CONSULTANT.
YOU KNOW THE ROLE -- IS PROBABLY
YET TO BE DETERMINED BUT
CERTAINLY THE AGES OFFICE IS YOU
KNOW ASSUME THIS RESPONSIBILITY
OF TAKE A MORE ACTIVE ROLE WHEN
IT COMES TO MEMEL JUSTICE ISSUES --
WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT YOU KNOW
IF YOU.
MISTER CHAIR I JUST UNDERLYING
RIGHT NOW OPR DOESN'T CONSULT
WITH ANYBODY ELSE THE COORDINATE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION NATURAL RESOURCES
ON PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
ON THE SAME PAGE NOT.
CONSULTED HAS.
IT COULD HAVE A POSITIVE EFFECT
THAT WE WANT YOUR INPUT OR CAN
HAVE A YOU KNOW.
YOU GET TO VETO POWER OR
SOMETHING LIKE ON A PLANNING
DOCUMENT WHICH IS I THE REASON
I'M RAISING THIS IS THAT I HOPE
THAT THAT'S NOT IT THAT THAT'S
THAT THAT SAID THIS IS A CHECK
IN.
AND IF THEY SEE THAT THERE'S A
CONCERN.
THE LATTER IS MY SENSE OF WHERE
THE BILLS BUT THE BILL'S FRIENDS
HERE IS THAT IS THAT RIGHT YEAH
ABSOLUTELY IS THERE I MEAN IT WE
NEED.
LANGUAGE CLARITY OF THE THE ARE
YOU CONCERNED ABOUT IT NOT
[inaudible]
ADEQUATELY.
EXPRESSING THAT I THINK THE
ATTORNEYS I THINK THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS HEARD YOUR
CONCERNS AND WHAT THE I THINK
THE RIGHT BALANCE WOULD BE WITH
THE OPR.
IN THE IN THIS PLANNING PROCESS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
BACKGROUND.
DID YOU WANT TO MAKE SENATE VOTE
COMMENT YEAH AND THEN -- GIVEN
THE ORGAN THE SENATE JUDICIARY
NEXUS IS SOMETHING YOU CAN
DEFINITELY HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE CLARITY AND ARE WORKING
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE AND THE LANGUAGE THE WE
CAN ACTUALLY CLARIFY BUT I THINK
LIKE YOU MENTIONED IS A LOT --
FOR US IS REALLY IT'S NOT REALLY
HAVING IT IN ANOTHER.
YOU KNOW BARRIER AND IN THE
PROCESS OF REALLY HAVING A
BETTER SENSE OF HOW THE PROCESS
CAN B FACILITATED TO INCLUDE A
LOT OF COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN A SNAP SOME KIND.
RIGHT OKAY -- ONCE AGAIN ONCE
AGAIN JUST THE THE ONE ON THE
BALL TODAY.
SO THE MOVED IF YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ON AMBER -- HAVE NOTHING
ELSE SO SORRY I'M SO SORRY
MEADOW VICE CHAIR OF THE CASE
QUESTION WE GOT UP TO I DIDN'T
JERKY STARTS WITH THE PHONE.
I JUST HAVE A PROBLEM THAT WE
ARE BASICALLY -- CODIFYING HE
AGENCY WITHIN AN AGENCY A BUREAU
THAT WAS NEVER REVIEWED BY.
THE LEGISLATURE AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY YOU GET SOME OF THE
CONFUSION ABOUT.
WHO COMES FIRST IN TERMS OF THE
REVIEW PROCESS IN THE DIRECTION
SO I CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BUT I WOULD HOPE GOING
FORWARD THAT THERE'D BE SOME
CONSIDERATION?
ABOUT A MORE DEFINITIVE THE
DEFINITION OF THE MURALS
RESPONSIBILITY HE SERVES ON IT.
AND THE RELATIONSHIP.
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM.
FREMONT ABROAD OUT.
BECAUSE WE ARE COMMITTING TAX
DOLLARS TO A NEW AGENCY IF YOU
WILL.
AND IT HAS RATHER FAR REACHING
ALL RESPONSIBILITIES AND
AUTHORITIES OVER SOMETHING
SIFTING.
ACOSTA SIS THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
I BELIEVE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
REVIEWED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
AND CODIFIED OR LIKE THE CART
BEFORE THE HORSE HERE IS MY
CONCERN SO -- GOING FORWARD I
WON'T SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT
CERTAINLY HAVE AN OPEN MIND
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN THE WAY
REVIEWING IT FROM OBVIOUSLY JUST.
IS IMPORTANT.
WHAT WE SHOULD THE COMMENTS WILL
CERTAINLY -- WE'LL DO OUR BEST
TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES
[inaudible]
CLOSE.
I HAVE NOTHING ELSE TO ADD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK -- FOR AND I
THINK THE SENATE SO THE MATTER
HAS BEEN MOVED ASSEMBLY CASKEY
AS SUCH IT WAS KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B. SIXTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
ALLEN HI ALLEN I BATES SNOW.
WITH SNOW HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
STERN.
STONE STILL NO WHITE HOUSE.
THE CASKET HI.
OKAY WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN WE
DO APPRECIATE AND EVERYONE
COMING FROM THOSE BILLS AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOONER.
OKAY OUT WILL NEXT HEAR FROM A
SUMMER GARCIA WHO GOT HERE
TWENTY SECONDS AFTER.
RIVAS I YOU ARE THIS IS YOU ARE
YOU PRESENTED THIS MORNING
YOU'RE JUST ON A ROLL TODAY.
WE'LL GIVE YOU AS MUCH TROUBLE
AS WE POSSIBLY CAN HERE I YOU'RE
PRESENTING AB TWO NINETY THREE
WHICH HAS TO DO WITH OFFSET
PROTOCOLS.
ME BEGIN BY SAYING THAT I I AM
NOT A LAWYER HI AND I WILL BE
ABLE TO ANSWER ANY OF THOSE VERY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS BUT THE TWO
WITNESSES HERE WELL.
YOU KNOW IT ISN'T OFTEN THAT AN
AGENCY OF THE STATE ASKS FOR A
DIRECTION.
AS A RESULT OF A POLICY ADOPTION
IN THIS CASE.
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD IS
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL DIRECTION
FOR THE COMPLIANCE OFFICE IT.
CAUGHT TASK FORCE -- AS THEY
WILL BE CONVENING AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WILL
POINT TO SEVERAL POTENTIAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR NEW OPPOSITE
PROTOCOLS THAT WILL COMPLY WITH
THE DEFINITION.
OF A DIRECT ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFIT TO CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO POINT TWO
KEY ISSUES PREVENTING CURRENT
CALIFORNIA PROJECTS FROM
QUALIFYING.
OPPOSITE PROJECTS SPECIFICALLY
THE ABILITY FOR SMALL LAND.
OWNERS. TO WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE
THE PROJECT COST EFFECTIVE.
WE THINK OF AND NETWORKING LANDS
PROJECTS WE THINK OF CLIMATE
SMART AG PROJECTS AS WELL AS A
WEAPON IN PROJECTS THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY QUALIFY.
AS THE OPPOSITE -- FOR THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM UNDER THE
DEFINITION OF THE 50% IN
CALIFORNIA DIRECT BENEFIT.
ALSO THE FOR THOSE ERE
WONDERING WHAT POTENTIALLY THIS
BILL MAY DO.
A WITH US TODAY IS ONE OF THEM
AND I KNOW WITH THE AUDUBON.
AS WELL AS JUDGING AMERO FROM
CAL CAN TO BE MORE SPECIFIC ON
WHAT -- COULD RESULT AS FROM
THIS BILL AND GIVE -- THE A
RESOURCES BOARD CLEAR DIRECTION --
MOVING FORWARD AS RESULT OF AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU.
WHAT I MEAN I KNOW THANK YOU --
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
I'M WITH THE ITEM ON CALIFORNIA
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT WITH AB
TWO NINETY FOUR AB.
TWO NINETY THREE OUT OF ON
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A LONGTIME
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIANS LAND
CONSERVATION AND AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION FOR THE
BENEFIT OF WILDLIFE.
AND PEOPLE AUDUBON'S MISSION IS
TO RESTORE AND CONSERVE NATURAL
ECOSYSTEMS FOCUSING ON BIRDS AND
OTHER WILDLIFE AND THEIR
HABITATS.
AB TWO NINETY THREE IS A SIMPLE
COMMON SENSE BILL THAT REQUIRES
AS ARE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA SAID.
CLIMATE OFFSET PROTOCOL -- TASK
FORCE TO BE APPOINTED BY THE A.
R. R. A. R. D. -- TO CONSIDERED
THE DEVELOPING ADDITION TO
CONSIDER DEVELOPING ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITE PROTOCOLS RELATED TO
THE ENHANCED MANAGEMENT OR
CONSERVATION OF AGRICULTURAL.
IN NATURAL LANDS FOR THE
ENHANCEMENT AND READ IT.
ENHANCEMENT AND RESTORATION OF
WETLANDS IN OTHER AREAS WE
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
NATURAL WORKING LANCE -- MUST BE
AN EXPLICIT PART OF THE STATE'S
OVERALL CLIMATE STRATEGIES NOT
ONLY TO REDUCE.
EMISSIONS BUT ALSO TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES AND RESOURCES
FROM THE IMPACTS ALREADY IN
MOTION.
WHILE THE STATE HAS TAKEN SOME
INITIAL STEPS ARE TO BUILD
NATURAL AND WORKING LINES INTO
INTO CLIMATE POLICIES SIGNIFICAN
IN MORE ACTION IS NEEDED. TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S LANDS
ARE.
A HEALTHY CARBON SINK AND HELP
YOU MAKE COMMUNITIES.
AND NATURE ADOPTED THE CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO SEE A MANY OTHER MEMBERS HERE
HAVE SUPPORTED NUMBER OF NATURAL
WORKING LANDS INITIATIVES AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS [inaudible]
THIS POLICY.
SIMPLY ALLOWS FOR CLARITY FROM
THEY ARE BE. TO THE A. R. B. TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
AS THEY BEGIN TO IMPLEMENT --
THESE PROTOCOLS THAT WE DO IT IN
SUCH A WAY THAT IS.
ENHANCING THESE AREAS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME'S JEANNIE
MARYLAND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK
WE ARE A COALITION OF
SUSTAINABLE AND ORGANIC
AGRICULTURE ORGANIZATIONS -- OUR
FARMERS DON'T PARTICIPATE IN THE
CALIFORNIA CARBON MARKET -- WE
ONLY HAVE ONE FUNCTIONAL OFFSETS
PROTOCOL THAT IS WORKING FOR
FARMERS AS RETIREE DIE JESTERS --
ARM OUR MEMBERS DON'T
PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROGRAM SO
IT'S NOT WORKING FOR THEM.
SOME.
IT COSTS THE TRANSACTION COSTS
FOR FARMERS TO PARTICIPATE ARE
TOO HIGH OR TOO FEW PROTOCOLS
AND ESSENTIALLY CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT HAVE FUNCTIONAL AGGREGATION
OF ALL SET PROJECTS THE
AGGREGATION IS THE IDEA THAT A
GROUP OF FARMERS WOULD COME
TOGETHER -- THAT WE SHOULD LOWER
THEIR TRANSACTION COSTS AND THEN
THEY CAN PARTICIPATE IN THE
CARBON MARKET BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THAT'S NOT HOW IT'S WORKING
VERIFICATION COSTS REMAIN TOO
HIGH AND AS A CONSEQUENCE.
OF FARMERS -- CAN'T PARTICIPATE
IN THE CARBON MARKET IT ALSO
MAKES IT VERY THERE'S NOT MUCH
OF AN INCENTIVE -- FOR
DEVELOPERS IN CALIFORNIA TO
DEVELOP NEW -- PROTOCOLS THAT
ARE RELEVANT -- FOR CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE BECAUSE THEY KNOW
IT'S GONNA BE REALLY TOUGH. TO
GET FARMERS TO PARTICIPATE WE
THINK A. B..
RAISES THE BAR A LITTLE BIT
PRIORITIZE IS THE IMPORTANCE OF
NATURAL WORKING LANDS -- OFFSET
PROJECTS -- AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT -- ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF FOLKS WANT TO ADD ON
GOOD MORNING CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS THREE
SEPARATE IMAGE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOST COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
IS -- ELEVEN SALAS WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING NATALIE KNOCKS ON
BEHALF OF MY PENCIL REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND SUPPORT.
MORNING MR CHAIR MARK FENSTER
MAKER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT.
THE CHAIR TONY BRUNELLO
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
FORCED CARBON COALITION WHICH
HAS TEN OF THE LARGEST FORCED
OFFSET PROVIDERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
OKAY -- ANYONE WANTS TO RAISE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS.
NO OKAY AS I WAS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS --
SENATE HELLO THIS RESTAURANT.
OBSERVE A CASKET I HAVE I HAVE A
CONCERN I APPRECIATE.
THE EFFORT HERE WHAT I'M I WANT
TO RAISE A POINT WITH REGARD TO
THAT JOINT LETTER THAT WE SENT
ITS REFERENCE IN THE REPORT --
TO THE AIRPORT ABOUT THE OFFSET
PROTOCOLS IN ABOUT THE
VERIFICATION OF THE OFFSETS AND
I'M WONDERING HOW THE TIMING
WORKS IS THAT.
THE BILL WAS INTRODUCED IN
FEBRUARY AND MEND IN APRIL WE
SENT THE LETTER TO THE AIRPORT
SAYING WE HAVE SOME SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW OFFSETS ARE
CALCULATED WE'VE GOT -- EITHER A
20% LEAKAGE THAT THE AIR BOARD
AGREES TO OR AN 80% LEAKAGE
WHICH IS THE CLIMATE.
ACTION RESERVE SAYS AND WE GET A
BLOW OFF LETTER FROM THEM.
WE GET A WE GET A BLOW OFF
LETTER FROM THE AIR RESOURCE
BOARD SO NOW WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE WE'RE THE THE BILL.
IS.
ASKING FOR RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THIS COMPLIANCE OFFICE PROTOCOL
TASK FORCE.
THEY'RE NOT ANSWERING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE QUESTIONS
BY THE LEGISLATURE.
AND I'M WONDERING IF IT SENDS
THE WRONG MESSAGE TO SEND THE
TIMING.
I BELIEVE I SIGNED ON TO THE
LETTER YOU DID YOU DID AND I
ALSO SIT ON THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD OF THE EXHIBITION BOARD
MEMBER AND SO.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
FOLLOWING UP WITH THEM -- WE SEE
THIS KIND OF AS AN AND PARALLEL --
THEY'VE ASKED FOR SOME.
DIRECTION.
AND THIS IS WHAT WE'RE KIND OF
PUTTING BEFORE THEM -- I KNOW
THAT THE OFFICE OF PROTOCOL TASK
FORCES SET TO MEET.
OUR TOWARDS THE END OF THIS YEAR.
AND WE ANTICIPATE.
SOME MOVEMENT I'M HOPING THAT
THIS BILL WILL KIND OF STIMULATE
SOME CLEAR DIRECTION AND ALSO
SOME.
MORE CLEAR RESPONSE -- FROM THEM.
TO OUR LETTER SO -- HAPPY TO
REPORT BACK TO YOU AND WORK WITH
YOUR REPRESENTATIVE -- ON THE
AIR RESOURCES OARD WHICH IS
SENATOR -- MONEY YES -- TO
ENSURE THAT WE MORE SUBSTANTIVE
A RESPONSE. TO THE LETTER THAT
WE SENT. TO THEM SELECT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT THE TASK
FORCE WILL BE ABLE TO WITH
CHEESE IN THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT.
WAS NOT.
DELINEATED IN OUR LET HER.
AS FAR AS THE DIFFERENCES OF THE
THAT THE DEFICIENCIES IN THE
CURRENT OFFICE AND PROGRAM.
WELL I THINK WE SHARE SOME OF
YOUR FRUSTRATIONS -- AND ARE
WANTING TO SEE -- THERE
RESOURCES BOARD PRIORITIZE THE
ABILITY OF SMALL LANDOWNERS
FARMERS TO PART.
OUR HOPE IS THAT THROUGH BY
ELEVATING THESE ISSUES TO THE
TASK FORCE -- THAT WILL SPUR
GREATER ATTENTION AT THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD FOR THESE ISSUES
THERE HAVE BEEN CONVERSATIONS AT
AIR BE AROUND.
THE HIGH COST OF PARTICIPATION
IN THE CARBON MARKET -- THERE
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSIONS AROUND
WAYS -- TO ALLOW FOR THE
INTEGRITY OF PROJECTS BUT MORE
CHEAPLY VERIFY THEM -- SO THAT
GREATER ACCESS IS IS POSSIBLE WE
THINK THAT THE TASK FORCE CAN
SEIZE UPON SOME OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE HOPE ELEVATE
THEM.
AND PRIORITIZE THEM IN A WAY
THAT WE JUST SIMPLY HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO DO SO FAR YEAH AND I'M
JUST CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FUNDAMENTAL INCONSISTENCIES AS
WEPOINTED OUT.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE FOREST LAND I MEAN THE
THE THIS IS THE STATE SENATE.
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM AND
ANOTHER FOR MANURE MANAGEMENT
RAT RATHER THAN -- GESTURES FOR
YOUR CONSTITUENCY BUT WE CAN'T
EVEN AGREE ON HOW YOU COUNT THE
HUNDRED YEAR FOREST -- OFFSETS
WITH THE IT'S IN ONE YEAR WHEN
YOU CUT DOWN THE TREES OR OVER
THE COURSE OF A HUNDRED YEARS
AND AND I GUESS I'M SO
DISSATISFIED WITH THE RESPONSE
THAT I GOT THAT I'M WORRIED THAT.
THAT THIS IS AN ACQUIESCENCE OF
YOU KNOW GOING FOR WITH THIS
BILL GIVEN HOW THEY YOU KNOW
RESPONDED TO YOU AND I AND
EVERYBODY ELSE WHO SIGNED THIS
LETTER -- SO ONE THING YOU KNOW
I I AM.
COMMITTED TO IS KIND OF
CONTINUING TO PUSH THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE RAISED IN.
THAT LETTER -- TO THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
AS I MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS THE TASK FORCE.
pTIME -- AT THE END OF THIS YEAR.
SO MANY OF THESE QUESTIONS THAT
WILL BE RAISED AND HOPING THAT
WERE ABLE TO GIVE SOME --
ELEVATION IT WAS MENTIONED TO
SOME OF THESE ISSUES THAT WERE
PRESENT IN HERE.
IN THIS PARTICULAR POLICY BUT
ALSO THAT WERE RAISED IN THE
QUEST IN THE ACTUAL LETTER THAT
WE COLLECTIVELY SIGN ON TO ARE
COMMITTED TO CONVENE PUSHER AND
I'M SURE THAT YOUR
REPRESENTATIVE CENTER MONNING
WOULD BE -- VERY HELPFUL IN THAT
EFFORT AS WELL.
I WILL EXPRESS TO HIM MY SENSE
OF URGENCY TO MEETING THE TWENTY
THIRTY TARGETS AND I'M NOTHING
SHORT OF FURIOUS WITH THE AIR
RESOURCE BOARD ON THIS RESPONSE
AND AGAIN I JUST LATER.
REESE MY CONCERNS THAT THAT.
IN THE THERE MAY BE A
MISINTERPRETATION OF OUR
ACQUIESCENCE WITH.
WITH THE WAY THAT THE BILL IN
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE THAT SIN
RIGHT NOW THAT IT'S NOT.
MORE FORCEFUL ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EGGMAN IT'S YOUR BILL IT'S YOUR
BILL HI BUT BUT IT'S NOT MORE
FOR SPOKE TO SAY YOU'VE GOT TO
HEAR SOME BARE MINIMUMS ON ON
WHAT WE THINK THAT THE PROTOCOL
SHE'LL BE AND YES WE'D LIKE THE
THE TASK FORCE THE ELEVATED BUT
THIS IS THE FLOOR. FOR GOD SAKES
AND BUT THAT OF RETURN. TO THE
CHAIR.
YEAH I KNOW I APPRECIATED I IM.
YEAH I'M AS AS YOU KNOW THIS
WHOLE BOSSA CONVERSATIONS
CONTROVERSIAL AND AND THERE'S A
LOT OF BACK AND FORTH ON THIS.
I CERTAINLY IF IF THERE'S ANY
ANTICIPATION OF SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES THIS BILL WHAT WE WANT
TO HAVE IT BACK HERE THIS
COMMITTEE BUT TIME.
HI BUT I THINK IT'S A IT'S A
IT'S A REASONABLE ANSWER LEAN
WITHIN LINE WITH WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DO.
IN THIS AREA SO -- YEAH -- YES
CENTER HELL.
YEAH YOU YOU YOU'VE YOU'VE BEEN
VERY PATIENT -- SO -- SENATE
BILL MOVES THE BILL -- WITHOUT
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIRTY PLEASE COLOR OF ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB TWO NINETY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN.
ALLEN RIGHT BATES.
BATES AYE HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
STERN.
STERN AYE STONE.
STONE I LIKE KELSEY.
HI.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MUCH THANK
YOU AS A MEMBER I I SEE SOME
MEMBER OBERNOLTE IS HERE. TO
PRESENT ITEM NUMBER TWO IN YOUR
PACKET THAT'S AB.
THREE NINETY FOUR OTHERS LAURA
FRIEDMAN HIDING IN THE BACK.
WOW LOOK AT YOU.
OKAY.
YOUR NEXT.
AS A MEMBER.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- I'M SURE EVERYONE ON
THE COMMITTEE IS FAMILIAR WITH
THE DEVASTATING CAMPFIRE FROM
LAST YEAR WAS THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE AND DEADLY FIRE IN
CALIFORNIA STATE HISTORY.
IT COMPLETELY DESTROYED THE TOWN
OF PARADISE BY THE POINT UNITS
BERRIEN SEVERAL MONTHS AGO WITH
ALONG WITH SEVERAL OF YOU OF
TOURING THE DEVASTATED TOWN.
LICENSING FIRSTHAND THE
DESTRUCTION OF THAT FIRE HAD
WROUGHT.
I'LL TELL YOU SOME.
A FASCINATING STATISTICS ABOUT
THAT FIRE OVER HALF OF THE
STRUCTURES THAT WERE BURNED BY
THAT FIRE WERE BURNED WITHIN TWO
HOURS OF THE FIRES IGNITION
THAT'S HOW FAST THAT FIRE SPREAD.
AND SOME OF THE MOST AMAZING
TESTIMONY THAT WE HEARD WHEN WE
WERE.
IN THE TOWN OF PARADISE WAS FROM
THE FIRST RESPONDING AGENCIES
THEY TOLD US ABOUT COMPLETE
GRIDLOCK GETTING OUT OF PARADISE
THAT DAY.
DICE HAS FOUR DIFFERENT EGRESS
ROUTES AND ALL FOUR OF THEM WERE
COMPLETELY CLOGGED WITH DISABLED
VEHICLES BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE A
FIRE THAT MOVES THAT QUICKLY.
OBVIOUSLY WHEN PEOPLE SEE THE
FLAMES ADVANCING TOWARDS THEM
THEY JUST BILLION THEY LEAVE
THEIR VEHICLES WHERE THEY ARE
AND SO NO ONE COULD GET OUT
AFTER THAT OCCURRED.
AND SO WE HAD THE THE HIGHWAY
PATROL AND THE SURE OF TELLING
US ABOUT PEOPLE SHELTERING IN
THE MIDDLE OF INTERSECTIONS IN
THEIR CARS BECAUSE THAT WAS AS
FAR AS THEY CAN GET AWAY FROM.
OF FLAMMABLE VEGETATION OTHER
OTHER PEOPLE THE TESTIFIED ABOUT
GOING AND FINDING A MEADOW BUT
THEY COULD SHELTER IN THE MIDDLE
OF UNFORTUNATELY MOST OF THOSE
PEOPLE SURVIVED IT REALLY
ILLUSTRATES.
THE PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH LACK OF EGRESS
TO SOME OF OUR MOST FIRE PRONE
COMMUNITIES.
OF THIS BILL AB THREE NINETY
FOUR IS A SMALL RESPONSE TO THAT
IT CRACKED CREATES A VERY
NARROWLY CRAFTED EXEMPTION TO
SEE WHAT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CREATING.
NEW EGRESS ROUTES OUT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THE REBEL FIRE PRONE
AND THE DON'T HAVE SUFFICIENT
EGRESS.
SO.
WHICH WE TALKED ABOUT FOR OF
PARADISE HAVING FOUR DIFFERENT
EGRESS ROUTES MANY COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE FEWER THAN THAT IN FACT I
LIVE IN A COMMUNITY WITH ONLY
THREE THERE ARE MANY COMMUNITIES
WITH ONLY TWO OR ONLY SINGLE
EGRESS ROUTE AND SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO STRIKE.
A VERY APPROPRIATE BALANCE
BETWEEN TRIED PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND PROVIDE PROJECTS
APPROPRIATE REVIEW ON THE ONE
HAND AND ALLOWING FOR THESE
PROJECTS TO MOVE FORWARD IN
SOLVING THIS IMPORTANT PROBLEM
ON THE OTHER HAND SO I DIED
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR AYE
VOTE ON AB.
THREE NINETY FOUR THANK YOU SOME
MEMBER CAN I JUST CONFIRM THAT
YOU ARE TAKING IMMENSE FROM THE
COMMITTEE THE MEN OF ARE THE
AMENDMENTS OKAY LET'S TALK ABOUT
AMENDMENTS MISTER CHAIRMAN --
HALF THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS I THINK
MAKE THE BILL BETTER IT ALIGNS.
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR THIS FOR THESE
EGRESS PROJECTS WITH THE
EXPEDITED FOREST MANAGEMENT
PROJECTS AT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED.
I THINK THEY DO MAKE THE BILL
BETTER IN THEIR CORPORATE WE'RE
HAPPY TO TAKE THOSE HOWEVER I
HAVE TO EXPRESS A LITTLE BIT OF
FRUSTRATION.
BECAUSE I'M A DETAIL GUY AND I
WHEN I TALK ABOUT AMENDMENTS I
LIKE TO SEE LANGUAGE AND SO I I
UNDERSTAND THE COMMITTEE HAS
SOME DRAFT LANGUAGE THAT I
WASN'T ALLOWED TO SEE THEY
WOULDN'T GET IT TO ME.
MILEAGE RECORDS COME IN MAKE
NOTES BUT HE COULDN'T TAKE A
COPY AND SO I HAVEN'T READ.
WHAT THE COMMITTEE HAS COME UP
WITH SO I HAVE SOME THAT WE WE
TAKE OUR BEST STAB AT TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE COMMITTEE
WAS GETTING OUT AN ACT IF IF IF
YOU'D LIKE I'LL READ THEM? TO
YOU WHAT WHAT WE'RE SUGGESTING
WE DO WITH THE BILL [inaudible]
I'M.
OKAY -- I MEAN IT WILL LET ME.
WITH THAT WELL LET ME ASK LET ME
LET LET ME LET HIM PROCEED LET
ME JUST ASK YOU ARE YOU ARE YOU
CONCEPTUALLY ABSOLUTELY ON THE
SAME PAGE WITHOUT ABSOLUTE THE
WAS IT JUST A MATTER SHERMAN WAY
WHICH IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THERE
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT --
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT
WHEN WE LET YOUR WITNESS PERCENT
ENEMIES HAVE A QUICK SIDEBAR
STAFF ON THIS -- YES SIR.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE ROLE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WE'RE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BILL -- AS MR OBERNOLTE
NOTED IT IS VERY NARROWLY
TAILORED IT IS ONLY --
APPLICABLES AUX IN HIGH FIRE
RISK AREAS AND ONLY FOR THOSE
PROJECTS IDENTIFIED BY THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY THE B. O. F. UNDER
AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN IS GOING
TO GO OUT AND IDENTIFY PROJECTS
THAT ARE NEEDED FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ONLY HAVE ONE
EGRESS ROUTE.
SO THIS IS EXACTLY THE TYPE OF
EXPEDITED CONSTRUCTION OF THOSE
PROJECTS IT FILLS A GAP WHERE
EXISTING SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS JUST
DON'T WORK -- EXEMPTIONS FOR
ROAD SAFETY PROJECTS THAT MISTER
OBERNOLTE HAD -- EXTENDED THE
SUNSET DATE LAST ESSION --
THOSE EXISTING EXEMPTIONS
GENERALLY ONLY APPLY TO COUNTY
IS LESS THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE SO THAT EXEMPTS THE TOP
THIRTY FIVE COUNTIES BY
POPULATION FROM BEING ABLE TO
USE THAT FOR THESE PURPOSES.
AND THERE'S ALSO A PROVISION IN
THERE THAT SAYS THAT IT CAN'T
INCREASE CAPACITY -- WILL YOU
KNOW IF YOU NEED A SECONDARY
ADDRESS ROUTE WERE TO IMPROVE A
SECONDARY ADDRESS ROUTE YOUR BY
DEFINITION GOING TO INCREASE
CAPACITY SO I THINK THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT SPECIFIC FOCUSED
SEQUEL EXEMPTION.
THAT WOULD REALLY BENEFIT THESE
COMMUNITIES AND REALLY IMPROVE
FIRE SAFETY.
THANK YOU SIR I TOOK THE ONE AT
ON IN SUPPORT.
SB WELCOME HAVE THE COUNTY OF
WHATEVER YOUR COUNTY FOR
SUPERVISORS ALSO SUPPORT YOUR
YOUR SINGLE PICKY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT -- CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE MISTER CHAIR CHRIS FOR
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING THE AS A RETURN CAL
CHAMBER ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THE MORNING SO YOU FROM HAVE THE
CIVIL JUSTICE CESSATION
CALIFORNIAN THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU'RE MUCH.
I ANYONE OPPOSITION TRUCKS
ONEROUS CONCERNS WITH THE BILL.
OKAY THE MEASURE FOR THE
COMMITTEE I SEE CENTER STONE WAS
AS QUESTION AND OUR STAFF SIR.
PROGRAMMING ON THE LANGUAGE
RELATED IMMENSE BUT THAT'S
UNDERSTAND YET JUST A QUICK
COMMENT MISTER CHAIR -- I
REPRESENT THE THE COMMUNITY OF
IDYLLWILD AND IDYLLWILD HAS ONE
WAY IN AND ONE WAY OUT.
AND THE CRANSTON FIRE WAS THERE
AND IT WAS ONE OF TWO MAJOR
FIRES -- IN MY DISTRICT AND THAT
WAS CAUSED BY AN ARSONIST
FORTUNATELY.
IT WAS STARTED AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE MOUNTAIN NOT AT THE TOP OF
THE MOUNTAIN HAD STARTED AT THE
TOP OF THE MOUNTAIN.
WE WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THE OF
COURSE THE THE DEVASTATION
HAPPENED THE PARADISE FIRE WITH
ALMOST A HUNDRED ADDRESS WOULD
BE TALKING ABOUT PROBABLY TWO
THOUSAND US.
AND SO THIS TYPE OF LEGISLATION
IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR MY
MOUNTAIN COMMUNITY THAT UNDER
DURESS OF UNINSPIRED YOU
MENTIONED WITHIN TWO HOURS HOW
MANY STRUCTURES WERE.
WERE WERE LOST -- THIS THIS IS
GOING TO HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT
ON THE ABILITY FOR ISOLATED
COMMUNITIES TO QUICKLY EVACUATE.
AND AND GET AROUND THESE CLOGGED
CLOGGED ROADS THAT THE IN A
PROVIDE LIMITED THAT ACCESS TO
BE ABLE TO GET OUT.
SO I APPRECIATE YOU BRING IT
FORWARD IT IS VERY NARROW -- SO
I THINK -- OF THOSE THAT MIGHT
BE CONCERNED ABOUT IS SICK WITH
EXEMPTION SO WILL UNDERSTAND
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION IN A VERY.
ISOLATED -- AREAS OF THE STATE
WHICH THERE AREN'T AS A AS MANY.
AND SO -- I'D BE DELIGHTED TO TO
MOVE YOUR BILL AND HOPE WE GET A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE QUESTION FIVE YEAH SOME
ACOSTA.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER THE GOVERNOR'S
ISSUED ALLOWS FOR A SECONDARY
IGRICE ANYWHERE THAT THE FIRE --
STATE FIRE MARSHAL AND THE FORCE
OF THE PARTNER FOR STREET --
DETERMINES THEY NEED ONE THIS IS
THAT WOULD YOU AGREE WITH THAT --
LAST YEAR'S ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FRIEDMAN HAD A BILL THAT
DIRECTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY TO IDENTIFY FIRE PRONE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAD ONLY A
SINGLE EGRESS ROUTE.
AND WORK TOWARDS CONSTRUCTING A
SECOND AND THIS IS INTENDED TO
BE A FOLLOW ON BILL TO THAT --
TOO TO ALLOW THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THAT SECOND ROOM RIGHT BUT BUT
IT'S MORE THAN THAT BECAUSE
EXECUTIVE ORDER ALSO ALLOW FOR
THE IMPROVEMENT OF OF EXISTING --
ROADS TO IMPROVE THE THE EGRESS
AND INGRESS I GUESS ON THOSE CD
WOULD AGREE WITH THAT PRIDE.
I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND YOUR
QUESTION SETTLED THE THE LAW OR
GUESS.
OUR STAFF REPORT HIGHLIGHTS THE
LAW IS IS THAT THE FIRE MARSHAL
ALREADY HAS A SECRET EXEMPTION
TO IMPROVE THE ROADS THAT EXIST
IN THIS HIGH FIRE AREA THANK YOU
WHAT YOU'RE SPEAKING TO THAT
THEY CAN DO THAT NOW IF THERE'S
YOU KNOW NARAL NESS AND LIMIT
LIMITED -- MANEUVERABILITY THEY
CAN DO THAT RIGHT NOW TO IMPROVE
IT BECAUSE OF THE LESSONS THAT
WERE LEARNED.
RIGHT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
IMPROVEMENT AND THIS RENTALS A
LITTLE BIT BROADER THAN THAT
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
CREATION OF ADDITIONAL EGRESS
RIGHT I'M I'M GETTING THERE I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
KNOW THAT YOU CURRENTLY RIGHT
NOW UNDER THE SEAT.
THAT THE FIRE.
DEPARTMENT FOR SCREEN THE FIRE
MARSHAL CAN GO IN AND SAY WE
WANT TO IMPROVEMENTS THAT THESE
EXISTING.
ROADS WE WANTED IF WE DON'T HAVE
A SECONDARY EGRESS WE WANT TO WE
WANT TO CREATE A SECONDARY HE
CHRIS RIGHT SO THAT'S THAT'S
ALREADY THERE THE GUIDANCE THAT
WE'VE ADAPTED.
THIS WOULD ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
OF POTENTIALLY A THIRD FOURTH
ROAD THAT BOYS THAT WOULD
IMPROVE THE FIRE SAFETY.
I'M NOT I'M NOT -- DETERMINED
THAT BUT THAT'S THAT'S SUBJECT
TO ONE PUBLIC HEARING AND THE
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THAT --
SUPPORTER FOR STREET AND THE
FIRE MARSHAL SET YOUR
UNDERSTANDING RIGHT CERTAINLY
OUT IN ADDITION TO ALL OF THE
OTHER RESTRICTIONS IN OVERSIGHT
THAT HAS BEEN ADDED TO THE BILL --
BOTH IN THE ASSEMBLY ON HERE SO --
IT'LL BE SUBJECT ONCE WE GET
DONE WITH THE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
SUBJECT TO THE SAME OVERSIGHT
THAT THE FORCE MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES SUPPORT.
JUST THAT -- HAVE BEEN.
A PROPOSED BY GOVERNMENT NEW
SUMMERS SERVICES TO ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT -- THAT ONE'S
CONSTITUENCY HAS IS THAT WE HAVE
FIRE ROADS AND THEY'RE DESIGNED.
FOR AS WITH THE STATE FIRE ROADS
THE CONCERN IS THAT IF THOSE GET
IMPROVE THAT THEY BECOME REGULAR --
THOROUGHFARES IN THE MOUNTAIN
AREA I MEAN IF.
A IT MAY IMPROVE IN THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY WITH THERE'S A FIRE
PEOPLE GETTING OUT THAT'S THAT'S
AND BUT IT ALSO WOULD IMPROVE
THE INGRESS AND EGRESS.
DURING NORMAL TIMES IS IT DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT FIRE ROADS UNDER.
YOUR BILL.
AND YOUR BILL WOULD BE ABLE TO
MEET THAT -- IMPROVEMENT --
CRITERIA WELL I ACTUALLY HAVEN'T
THOUGHT ABOUT IT THAT WAY
SENATOR I'M JUST TRYING TO
CREATE NEW WAYS OF GETTING
PEOPLE OUT OF THESE COMMUNITIES
WHEN WE HAVE THESE DEVASTATING
FIRES THAT ARE SO FAST MOVING.
SO RIGHT THANK YOU SO I I'M I'M
TRYING TO MAKE A DETERMINED A
DIFFERENTIATION BETWEEN AN
ADDITIONAL FIRE ROAD THAT'S MADE
FOR IN THE EVENT OF A FIRE
HERE'S ANOTHER WAY TO GET OUT OF
THE CANYON OR UP ON THE HILL.
AND IMPROVING BECAUSE AS I CAN
MAYBE IT'S JUST IMPROVING THE
EXISTING ACCESS ROAD THAT THERE
WOULD BE A YOU KNOW PAVEMENT OF
ALL HE FIRE ROADS THAT ARE THERE
THAT WEREN'T REALLY DESIGNED FOR
PEOPLE TO BE ON ALL THE TIME SO.
I DON'T I JUST SPOTTING THE
ISSUE I'M NOT REALLY SURE --
WHAT THE AMENDMENTS ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO WAIT A MINUTE I'M GONNA
DEFER TO MY EX GREAT?
SO WITH RESPECT TO THOSE FIRE
ROADS -- I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THE BOARD OF FORESTRY
RECOGNIZED IS THAT SOMETIMES YOU
HAVE THESE FIRE ROADS -- THEIR
DIRT ROADS LEADING IN THE MIDDLE
OF NO WHERE -- THROUGH THE
MIDDLE OF A FOREST IN THE EVENT
OF A FOREST FIRE AND SO YOU HAVE
PEOPLE WHO ARE.
SCARED AND THEY'RE SCARED TO USE
THOSE VIRUS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
EXACTLY SURE WHERE THEY WILL
LEAD THEM THERE ON IMPROVE
TOWARDS ARE GOING TO BE --
CHALLENGES GETTING YOUR CAR OUT
THAT FIRE ROAD THAT YOU WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE WITH MAYBE.
A FIRE ENGINE OR SOMETHING SO I
THINK THIS BILL AND THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY OR LOOKING AT WAYS TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE
ABILITY TO USE THOSE FIRE ROADS.
THAT MIGHT BE PAVING IT MIGHT BE
REALLY WHATEVER THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY DETERMINES WOULD MAKE
THE PUBLIC FEEL SAFER TO USE
THOSE ROAD SUCCESSFULLY IN THE
EVENT OF A FIRE.
AIM IS CHAIRED FALLING ON THAT.
IN THE EVENT OF A FIRE YOU YOU
SAID.
THESE WOULD ALSO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
USE THOUGH NOT IN THE EVENT OF
FIRE CORRECT [inaudible]
HE'S ROADS.
SO IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE ROADS I DO BELIEVE WOULD
HAVE TO BE OPEN -- SO YEAH YOU
COULDN'T HAVE CHANGE YOU
COULDN'T HAVE GATES ACROSS THE
ROADS BECAUSE THAT'S ANOTHER ONE
OF THE THINGS THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY IDENTIFIED AS BEING AN
IMPEDIMENT.
IF THERE'S YOU KNOW A GATE
ACROSS THE ROAD IT MIGHT BE
DIFFICULT. TO GET THROUGH IF
THERE'S A TRAIN IT MIGHT BE
DIFFICULT TO GET WORSE RIGHT.
I AM YEAH WE WENT THROUGH WOLSEY --
AND WE WERE LUCKY IN THAT.
SPECIFIC COAST HIGHWAY WHICH
ENDED UP BECOMING. ONE OF THE
MANY GRASSES -- THE FIRED AND
HIT AT THE SAME TIME EVERYONE
WAS STUCK ON IT.
MY GRANDPARENTS FOR SEVEN HOURS
SITTING THERE JUST SITTING DUCKS
BUT IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
COULD OF BUT THIS CANYON ROADS
TO AND THAT'S HOW WE LOST PEOPLE
BEEN LEASE MANY.
ON LOST TO PEOPLE.
SHORT TERM RESPIRATORY ANOTHER.
ISSUES BUT TO YEAH THIS GOES
BEYOND -- JUST SIMPLE NO SEEK
WHAT POLICY IF IT'S EVER
CONSIDERED SIMPLE INTO LIFE AND
DEATH ISSUE SO I RECOGNIZE THE
GRAVITY OF THE THE BILL -- IS
STILL TRYING TO GET I WANT TO
GET MY HEAD AROUND WHAT.
THE MEN'S YOU'RE GONNA BE AND
ALSO -- HOW THE?
THE TIMBER HARVEST PIECE IS
GOING TO WORK IN RESOURCES I
KNOW WE'RE DOUBLE REFERRED HERE
TODAY -- SO I WANT TO TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT ALL THAT BUT I
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATION AND I SORT OF I WANT
TO JUST.
GET A MORE THOROUGH LOOK AT
EXACTLY THESE ARE REALLY
SENSITIVE AREAS IT'S COMPLEX
CONSTRUCTION ENGINEERING ALSO TO
JUST TO TRY TO GET A BETTER
SENSE MAYBE EVEN FROM CAL FIRE
IN ADVANCE BUT WHAT WHAT WHAT
WE'RE EXPECTING AN ANSWER TO HOW
TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
COMMUNITY ABOUT.
WHAT WE CAN SEE?
YOU KNOW LIKE WHAT WE'RE COULD A
SECOND OR THIRD.
OR FOURTH EGRESS BE NECESSARY IN
PLACE LIKE TO PAYING A CANYON OR
UP IN THEIR STONE'S HILLS OR
WHEREVER ELSE SO.
DO YOU DO YOU HAVE THAT NOW IS
THAT SOMEONE WE CAN TRY TO KICK
THE TIRES ON BEFORE NEXT
COMMITTEE IF IT IF IT MAKES OUT
TODAY JUST TO SORT OF LOOK AT
WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM CAL FIRE
ALREADY ABOUT WHERE THE S. R. A.
NEEDS ARE.
IT DOESN'T WE NEED TO FLESH OUT
MORE YOU THINK YOU HAVE THAT
DATA NOW.
SO WE CAN GIVE A REASON LOW
EXPECTATION LEAST THE PUBLIC.
I MEAN I I GET THERE'S GONNA BE
A HEARING BUT WE WANT TO SIR I
WANT TO DO GOOD PUBLIC
COMMUNICATION IN THE FIRES ON
AND JUST LET ME KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE EXPECTING SO.
SURE WELL I'M HOPING THAT SOME
OF THE OVERSIGHT LANGUAGE WERE
HEADING TO THE BILL WILL GIVE
YOU SOME COMFORT THERE BECAUSE
AFTER TALKS ABOUT THINGS LIKE A
BEST FORCE MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
AND IN OVERSIGHT.
THE ONLY THING THEY HAVE I'M SO
UNDER THE BILL AMENDMENTS TAKEN
AN ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE BASICALLY SAY THAT ANY.
COMMERCIAL TIMBER THAT'S
HARVESTED HAS TO COMPLY WITH THE
FOREST PRACTICES ACT -- UNDER
THE SANITY Q. PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS OTHER PROVISIONS THAT
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE PROJECT
AND THE PROJECT APPLICANT TO
COMPLY WITH BEST.
PRACTICES AND RAGS TO THAT WERE
ADOPTED UNDER THE FOREST
PRACTICES ACT -- I THINK ONE OF
THE AUTHORS -- INTENSE WAS TO
CLARIFY THAT THOSE PROVISIONS
APPLY TO FORESTRY APPLY TO THE
REMOVAL OF TREES WITH RESPECT TO
SOME SORT OF WATER COURSES YOU
KNOW THEIR WETLANDS PROTECTIONS
BUILT INTO THE BILL ALREADY
SPECIES PROTECTIONS CAN'T IMPACT.
LISTED SPECIES -- SO THEIR
NUMBER PROTECTIONS ALREADY BUILT
IN THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS WILL
STILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
NORMAL CIVIL ENGINEERING PROCESS --
YOU'RE STILL GOING TO HAVE TO
OBTAIN ANY PERMIT APPROVALS OR
REVIEWS THROUGH STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
RIGHT AS FAR AS WE CAN GO
THROUGH ASHA.
I MEAN WITH THE SEEK REVIEW
COULD GO THROUGH ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE HABITAT AREAS IN
THEORY WITHOUT.
ANY IMMINENT Z. BERG THE THE
WORST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES DON'T
REALLY COVER THOSE THOSE
ENVIRONMENTS THE SAME WAY I
WOULD.
I WOULD HAVE TO DEFER TO
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL FORSTER
ON HOW THE FORCE PRACTICES ACT
DEALS WITH THOSE BY ABOUT IT I
THINK THE IMPORTANT THING IS
THAT.
THIS ISN'T NECESSARILY CHANGING
ANY OF THE OTHER SUBSTANTIVE
LAWS THAT ARE OUT THERE WITH
RESPECT TO PROTECTION OF THOSE
WATER COURSES.
SO IF THERE ARE -- PROTECTIONS
IN THE FISH AND GAME FISH AND
WILDLIFE CODE -- THE DEAL WITH
THOSE WATER COURSES -- IN THE
WATER CODE YOU'RE STILL GONNA
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THOSE. TO
THEN ARE YOU GONNA HIT IMPASSES
THAN IN THOSE AREAS.
WHERE YOU CAN'T ACTUALLY BUILD
THE EGRESS THAT YOU NEED IF IT
ISN'T ASHA LET'S FLESH THAT OUT
I I'M I'M VERY OPEN I DON'T MEET
AT I DON'T MEAN THIS IS A?
AS CRITIQUE PER SE BUT MORE JUST.
TO JUST TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE GETTING HERE
LIKE WHO WHO'S GONNA BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS KIND LIKE WHAT KIND OF
SUBDIVISION BE ELIGIBLE WHO
MIGHT BE OUT -- SO.
IF AND MAYBE EVEN BRINGING DID
YOU GUYS HAVE ANY REPORTS
INITIALLY FROM CAL FIRE ON THIS
ISSUE OF THE SORT OF STARTED TO
DO THE ANALYSIS OF WHAT.
MIGHT BE NEEDED SO IT'S MY TO
FORCE YEAH IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY STARTING ON THE LIST OF
PROCESS FOR STREET.
RIGHT THE BOARD OF FORESTRY ACT
HOW FAR IS STARTING ON THIS
PROCESS IT'S GOING TO BE A CASE
BY CASE.
SCENARIO HERE BECAUSE EVERY
COMMUNITIES DIFFERENT -- IT'S
NOT CLEAR HOW MANY COMMUNITIES
ARE OUT THERE -- THAT WOULD NEED
THIS TYPE OF ASSISTANCE.
RIGHT SO THEY'RE EVALUATING IT I
AM NOT AWARE THAT THEY HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES ARE CONCRETE
RECOMMENDATIONS YET OKAY AND
THEN JUST LAST DECENT PAYING FOR
THE INDULGENCE BUT LOCAL COUNTY
FIRE COUNTY RULES THIS IS AN S.
R. A FOCUS BILL HOW DO WE HOW DO.
HOW DOES IT APPLY WHO DO YOU SEE
THAT PLAYING ANSWER TO NINE THE
SO CAL FIRE TEAR TO ITS BOTH AS
OUR A AND LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY
AREAS BUT IT'S ONLY THOSE AREAS
IDENTIFIED AS A VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD OKAY SO WRIT LARGE
THROUGH VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY
SENSOR THEN?
YOU SEE COUNTIES THEN TAKING THE
LEAD ON ON THAT THIS SORT OF NON
S. ALREADY VERY HIGH.
BUYERS SEVERITY POTENTIALLY.
AND IF YOU AIN'T WITHIN ANY YOUR
COUNTIES ARE YOU ARE DO YOU HAVE
PLANS ALREADY THEY WERE YOU'RE
THINKING OKAY THIS IS A REALLY
DANGEROUS POCKET WE'VE GOT IT I
MEAN I CAN THINK OF THEM NOW
RIGHT I SO.
LIKE I THINK I REMEMBER COUNTIES
ARE INTERESTED -- AND THE SEE
THE BENEFIT OF THIS TYPE OF
SEQUEL EXEMPTION AND WHERE IT
TELLS THE GAPS LEFT BY OTHER
SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS.
AND CENTER WE ARE HAPPY.
TO WORK WITH YOU AND TAKE ANY.
SUGGESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE AS
THIS BILL MOVES THROUGH
COMMITTEE BECAUSE AS YOU POINT
OUT SPEND DOUBLE REFERRED BUT
YEAH ABOUT WORD WORD WE'RE
TRYING TO BE VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
DELIBERATE ABOUT THE PROCESSOR.
APPRECIATE.
OKAY -- YOUR BROTHER THE NUMBER
OF GOOD ISSUES IS THIS IS THIS
BILL GOING LET'S SEE SOFT.
IT'S GOING TO AND THAT'S GOING
TO RESOURCES ACCESO YEAH IT IS
AND IF IF YOU CAN GET.
I'M SURE YOU'LL HAVE THE VOTES
pPROBABLY WILL HOLD OFF TODAY AND
JUST SORT OF STAY OBJECTIVE AS
IT COMES TO COMMITTEE BUT I'VE
NO LIKE BIG.
ACTIONS HERE OKAY SELL OUT WELL
SO I'VE GOT A CHANCE AND IT
SEEMS AS THOUGH THERE ARE TWO
LITTLE DIFFERENCES -- THAT YOU
THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING VERSUS OUR
STAFF ONE OF THEM WE WERE WE
WOULD ADD IN LANGUAGE ABOUT
CONSULTING WITH THE APPROPRIATE
ENVIRONMENTAL RSOURCE SPECIALS
THAT'S THAT'S ABSOLUTELY FINE.
I THINK THE FIRST ONE YOU'RE
ASKING FOR IS A LITTLE MORE
COMPLICATED FOR US -- YOU KNOW
I'M.
I'VE I THINK THE I MY SUGGESTION
AND AND THAT'S OBVIOUSLY UP TO
YOU I WOULD BE THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD THE BILL TODAY PASS IT
OUT.
AND OUR STAFFS CONTINUE TO
NEGOTIATE I ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
FACT IT'S ABOUT TO GO OVER
NATURI SOURCES -- AND THAT WE
YOU KNOW.
I MEAN I CAN ARTICULATE YOU NOW
WHAT SOME OF OUR CONCERNS ARE
BUT WE CAN ALSO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION AFTER THE AFTER THE
HEARING -- I I I FEEL CONFIDENT
THAT WE CAN GET. TO TO MUTUALLY
AGREEABLE LANGUAGE I'M I'M NOT
SURE WHERE MORE READY TO ACCEPT
WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING.
WITH REGARDS TO LIMITING THE THE
EXEMPTION.
TO ADD TO TO THOSE SUCH ARTS ARE
LIMITING THAT THE CONVERSATION
OF THOSE PORTIONS OF PROJECT
INVOLVING TREE REMOVAL -- BUT I
I I DON'T I I THINK IT I THINK
YOU'RE GIVEN THE GRANTS GIVE
WHAT YOU TRY TO DO HERE WE WE
OUGHT TO PASS THE BILL OUT AND
AND HAVE OUR STAFFS CONTINUE TO
GO SHE ATE ESPECIALLY IN AN
AWESOME IN COURT.
EIGHT COORDINATION WITH THE
FOLKS ARE NATURAL RESOURCES THAT
WOULD BE MY SUGGESTION -- I THAT
WE MOVE FOR WITH THE MENS IS THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AND THEN
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING.
TO HONE IN ON OKAY SO TO BE
CLEARED.
WORD OF BECAUSE I I WAS JUST AND
I APOLOGIZE I I DON'T LIKE
COMING HERE NEGOTIATING LANGUAGE
ON THE DíAS I PREFER TO DO IT
AHEAD OF TIME SO THAT.
IT'S ALL DONE AND AND I WAS
FRUSTRATED.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT -- IN OTHER
THAT I WAS NEVER ALLOWED TO READ
THAT WHAT WAS THE COMMITTEE WAS
COMING UP WITH -- ON THE PROCESS
SO YES IS NO WAY I PREFER TO DO
IT EITHER -- SO ARE YOU
PROPOSING THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
ACCEPTING ONE OF THE CHANGES BUT
NOT THE OTHER WAY TO CONTINUE
TALKING ABOUT EXACTLY WE'RE
ACCEPTING THE SECOND CHANGE THE
APPROPRIATE ENVIRONMENTAL
RESOURCE PROFESSIONALS THAT THE
FIRST ONE WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TALKING ABOUT IT WILL COORDINATE
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES STAFF
AND AND THAT.
CAN HAPPEN YOU CAN TAKE THOSE --
MEN'S OVER THERE RIGHT THAT'S
ACCEPTABLE TO ME OKAY OKAY.
GREAT I AT THE BILL'S THE MOVE
BY CENTER STONE -- DO YOU KNOW
WHEN IT WILL GO NATURAL
RESOURCES IN THE CENTER HAS BEEN
SET.
THE ONLY SENSE NADA OKAY ALL
RIGHT WELL THERE'S TIME THIS IS
EARLY IN THE THIS EARLY IN THE
PROCESS. TWO WHAT WILL HAVE YOU
EVER OKAY OKAY FANTASTIC TO THE
BILL'S REMOVED BY CENTER STONE
I'M I'M CERTAINLY YOU
COMFORTABLE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TODAY THANK ALL THAT
UNDERSTANDING.
THE WORK ON ON THIS DIFFICULT
IMPORTANT ISSUE -- SURGICALLY
CORAL.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB THREE NINETY
FOUR MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER COMMITTEE.
ALLEN HI ALLEN I BATES.
BATES I STILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
STONE STONE I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
OKAY SO WILL WILL HOLD THAT ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS THAT ON
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE YOUR OF
YOUR WORK ON THIS AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU -- AND
WE'LL HAVE SOME FURTHER
CONVERSATION.
OKAY I SEE JUST REMEMBER MCCARTY
IS HERE -- HE'S HERE TO PRESENT
ITEM FIVE IN YOUR AGENDA PACKETS
MEMBERS THAT'S A. B.. EIGHT
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN
AND NECESSARY.
A BILL REALLY IN A SOLID WASTE
AND RECYCLING BINS ORGANIC.
WASTE -- YOU MAY PROCEED.
ONE YES THANK YOU.
ALL GOOD STUFF AS YOU JUST
OUTLINED -- SENATOR -- FIRST
THAT THANKS FOR WORKING WITH US
AND WE WOULD ACCEPT THE A
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AS PROPOSED BY YEAR AFTER NO
QUESTIONS NO NEGOTIATIONS.
NOT TODAY I DON'T KNOW I DON'T
WANT THE OBERNOLTE TREATMENT
HERE.
THIS IS.
YEAH.
YES SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
FRANKLY YOU CAN EASILY
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
STEP UP OUR RECYCLING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
OF COURSE WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT RECYCLES THOSE
LAWS IN THE FIRST PLACE AND
GETTING THEM.
A PROBE WE TAKING CARE OF IT BUT
ONE OF THE ISSUES IN MAKING SURE
WE HAVE A MORE -- CLEAN A SOURCE
RECYCLABLES FROM THE FRONT END
AND THIS IS AN ISSUE WHERE YOU
PROBABLY UNDERSTANDING YOUR
LIGHTS GOING.
TO ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAVE KIDS
GOING TO LET'S SAY A SUBWAY
BUYING A KID'S MEAL.
AND A IT COMES A LITTLE BOTTLE
WATER AFTER YOU EAT THE MEAL YOU
GO TO THROW A EVER ALL THE ALL
THE ALL THE ALL THE ALL THE
SCRAPS IN THE PAPERS IN THE
BOTTLES AND THAT THE AT THE
FRONT.
OF THE STORE THERE'S ONLY ONE
BEEN. FOR TRACK AND YOU ASKED
THE CLERK HEY WHERE WHERE DO WE
RECYCLE.
LIKE -- WE DON'T YET TO THROW
THE TRASH CAN BUT MANY THESE
RECYCLING THESE RESTAURANTS DO
HAVE RECYCLING IN THE BACK OF
THE RESTAURANT BUT NOT IN THE
FROM THE RESTAURANT SO.
FRANKLY SENDS A TERRIBLE MESSAGE
TO CONSUMERS AND KIDS THAT YOU
THROW RECYCLING YOU THROW
RECYCLABLES RIGHT IN THE TRASH
CANS SO.
MANY RESTAURANTS ALREADY DO THIS
YOU'VE PROBABLY SEEN IT AT
COSTCO AND MOVIE THEATERS AND
CHIPOTLE.
AND NEAR BRED TO THIS IS HAS
SOME OF THE OTHERS -- A STEP UP
AS WELL AND SO THIS WOULD
CERTAINLY HELP US WITH OUR GIGI
ISSUES AND RECYCLING AND FRANKLY
MORE IMPORTANTLY.
FOCUS ON PROPER RECYCLING IN THE
FRONT IN AND TEACH THE NEXT
GENERATION OUR YOUTH HOW TO DO.
IT PROPERLY I WITH ME TODAY ARE
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
REPUBLIC SERVICES -- ME
INTRODUCE MY WITNESSES THANK.
GOOD MORNING CHEN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NICK OFFICE OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
THIS BILL IS A FAIRLY SIMPLE
POLICY WE HAVE EXISTING LAWS ON
THE BOOKS THAT REQUIRE
BUSINESSES TO HAVE RECYCLING AND
COMPOSTING SERVICE.
THE SIMPLY SAYS THAT A BUSINESS
THAT IS ALREADY REQUIRED TO HAVE
THE SERVICE MUST PROVIDED TO ITS
CUSTOMERS.
IT REALLY TACKLES TWO SEPARATE
BUT REALLY IMPORTANT PROBLEMS.
FIRST IS AS THIS COMMITTEES WALL
WHERE WE'RE FACING A CRISIS WITH
OUR RECYCLING MARKETS.
THE MATERIAL THAT WE USE TO BE
ABLE TO SHIP OVERSEAS WITH
FAIRLY HIGH CONTAMINANTS.
I THOSE COUNTRIES NO LONGER WANT
AND THAT'S FORCING US TO RE LOOK
AT THE ENTIRE CYCLING SYSTEM.
PART OF THAT IS THE CHAIRS BILL
ABOUT PRODUCT REDESIGN.
AND SOURCE REDUCTION PART OF IT
IS MARKET DEVELOPMENT BUT ALSO
PART OF IT IS CLEANER SOURCE
SEPARATION. TO GIVING.
GIVING CUSTOMERS AND RESIDENTS
IN AND CONSUMERS OPPORTUNITY TO
PUT THINGS IN SEPARATE BINS.
BEFORE THEY GET COMMINGLED SO
THAT THE COMMODITIES ARE CLEANER
THEY'RE EASIER TO SELL THEM MORE
VALUE.
THE SECOND THING THE BILL
ACCOMPLISHES.
IS.
MOVING FORWARD WHERE FOCUS ON
ORGANICS DIVERSION AND
COMPOSTING.
AND AGAIN THAT'S ANOTHER.
ISSUE IT'S GONNA HAVE A LOT OF
MULTIPLE FACETS INCLUDING.
MARKET DEVELOPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE AT CETERA.
BUT A PART OF THAT IS ENSURING
THAT CONSUMERS HAVE ACCESS.
TO ORGANICS RECYCLING.
WHERE THEY WORK WHERE THEY GO
OUT TO EAT WHERE THEY LIVE?
AND THAT IS CONSISTENT ACROSS
THE BOARD SO THAT YOU SORT F
GET IN THE HABIT OF A BANANA
PEEL DOESN'T GO IN THE TRASH
CANS.
OF ANNA KILL GOES IN THE OTHER
BEEN.
AND UNLESS WE HAVE THAT KIND OF
CONSISTENT SYSTEM ACROSS THE
BOARD.
IT JUST WON'T WORK WHEN WE DROP
OFF BINS OF PEOPLE'S HOUSES AND
THEY HAVE NO IDEA.
WHAT TO DO WITH THEM -- THAT
ASSN AYE BOAT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKHAM PRAY OUT WITH
A FRIEND THE KELLY ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLIC SERVICES -- WE ARE ARE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT BY THIS MEASURE
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS REALLY
FROM TWO PERSPECTIVES.
OPERATIONALLY AND COST PRESSURES.
AS YOU ARE ALL WELL AWARE --
CHINA SOARED AND IT'S MUCH LOWER
CONTAMINATION STANDARDS HAVE
CAUSED A LOT OF SOLID WASTE THAT
WAS PREVIOUSLY RECYCLED TO BE
REJECTED.
AND THERE AREN'T MARKETS FOR
RECYCLED MATERIALS.
SECONDLY IS THAT IT IS -- AS A
RESULT OF THAT THERE IS A
PRESSURE -- TO PROVIDE --
GREATER -- RECYCLED CONTENT
INTERCLUB SKEWS ME.
THERE IS A IS A GREATER PRESSURE --
TO LOOK AT PROVIDING THE LESS
CONTAMINATION IN THE BILLS THAT
ARE BEING SOLD.
AND WITH THE ADVENT OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE A NEED TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OR OF ORGANIC
RECYCLING -- IN TAKING THAT OUT
OF LANDFILLS AS A RESULT THERE
IS INCREASING PRESSURE ON SOLID
WASTE OPERATORS TO SLOW THE
SYSTEM WHICH RESULTS IN HIGHER
COSTS.
IF SOLID WASTE COULD BE A BETTER
SOURCE SEPARATED THOSE --
PRESSURES WOULD NOT BE
ELIMINATED BUT WOULD BE REDUCED
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING AT IT FROM
A STANDPOINT THAT OPERATORS HAVE
A MUCH GREATER BURDEN IN TERMS
OF GETTING TO A LOWER --
CONTAMINATION RATE BUT ALSO AS A
RESULT OF THAT THEIR HIGHER COST
PRESSURES OR COMMERCIAL
CUSTOMERS ON OUR RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS AND ULTIMATELY ON THE
MUNICIPALITIES WHO FRANCHISE OR
SOLID WASTE FOR THOSE REASONS
WERE ASKING.
FOR IN THE SAME ISSUES THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH ON AND OTHER
LEGISLATION.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU OUR
FOLKS ONE ADD ON SUPPORT.
THERESA BURKE RICH ON BEHALF OF
THE LOCAL DMINISTRATORS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOST COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
EVERY THINK WASTE IN SUPPORT
FLORA COME ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
I ANYONE ELSE ANYONE WANTS TO
RAISE CONCERNS ARE OPPOSITION.
YES SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU MISTER TURN MEMBERS MET
CERTAIN THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION.
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE SPIRIT
OF THE BILL AND THE NOTION OF
CAPTURING THOSE RECYCLABLE
MATERIALS WHETHER THEIR FOOD
WASTE OR YOU KNOW PLASTIC
BOTTLES -- AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE OF WHAT WE'VE EXPRESSED
FROM THE BEGINNING IS THAT WE
ARE SO INCREDIBLY INVOLVED ON
THE CAL RECYCLE SIDE MAJOR
LEGISLATION THAT THIS HOUSE AND
BOTH HOUSES IN THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED SB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WHICH HAS
A REGULATORY STRUCTURE UNDER WAY
RIGHT NOW WHICH IN SHORT OUT OF
INTEREST OF YOUR TIME GETS US TO
THE SAME GOALS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WERE INVOLVED
IN THE REGULATORY ENVIRONMENTS.
IN THAT PROCESS AND IN THAT
PROCESS THERE'S A LOT OF LOCAL
CONTROL ELEMENTS WHICH ARE VERY
HELPFUL.
AND SPECIFICALLY WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT IS WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE FOOD WASTE AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE SORT OF
BLUE BEEN STUFF I GUESS WE'LL
CALL IT -- IN SO BOTH OF THOSE
ARE GOING TO BE REQUIRED UNDER
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
REGULATIONS AND IN THOSE
REGULATIONS THERE ARE --
FLEXIBILITY AS IF NOT WAIVERS
FOR SITUATIONS WHERE YOU HAVE
LIMITED SPACE IN A RESTAURANTS
BECAUSE KEEP IN MIND MOST OF OUR
RESTAURANTS AT THE INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANTS NOT THE CHAINS
MENTIONED.
AND WE DON'T HAVE CONTROL OF OUR
PHYSICAL FOOTPRINT AND SO
SOMETIMES WE CANNOT GROW AND WE
HAVE THAT LIMITED BUT PRINT.
AND SO THE LOCAL OF FLEXIBILITY
THAT IS IN THE REGULATIONS
ACCOMMODATES THAT SORT OF THING
TO BE DEVELOPED AND DETERMINED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL -- AND IN
ADDITION TO THAT -- SORRY
THERE'S A DE MINIMUS WAIVER SO
IF YOU HAVE A WHAT'S DEEMED AS A
REALLY SMALL AMOUNT OF ORGANIC
WASTE -- THAN THAT TOO CAN BE
ACCOMMODATED OR WAVE BUT TRUST
THE REAL BIG DEAL IS WHEN YOU
HAVE THE SPACE LIMITATIONS.
CAN YOU GET SOME FLEXIBILITY AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL SO THAT WE CAN
COMPLY WITH THE SPIRIT OF WHAT'S
HERE.
AND THE REGULATIONS OFFER A A
LONGER TIME FRAME TO TO GET TO
THIS POINT BY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO I THINK I
SHORT ASK WOULD BE I IS THERE I
THINK THERE'S A SWEET SPOT IN IS
THERE A WAY TO HAVE THIS BILL.
A LINE WITH THE REGULATIONS IN
TERMS OF TIMELINE AND IN TERMS
OF SOME OF THE LOCAL FLEXIBILITY
THE TOP.
THINK ABOUT WHAT ONE STAY FOR
SECULAR.
LET ANYONE ARE YOU ONE OUT ON IN
OPPOSITION.
CONCERNS OKAY COME ON IT IS REAL
QUICK -- DOES HERE ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN -- WASTE MANAGEMENT
THIRTY WESTERN UP FASTER WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY WE DON'T
HAVE A FOR A POSITION RIGHT NOW
CURRENTLY BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS AT THIS MAY CONFLICT.
WITH OUR CURRENT MAKES BASED
SITE.
AS CURRENTLY ALLOWED ONE AB
THREE FORTY ONE FOR HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AS WELL.
SENT TO MAYBE GET -- TO SOME
SORT OF LIKE. THREE POINT THAT
WE CAN GET SOME AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE CLARIFYING.
THE TAKE ANY OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
CONCERNS.
OKAY YES FOR THE COMMITTEE I
LOVE -- TO BEFORE WE GET OPEN UP
TO THE REST THE MEMBERS -- CAN
YOU SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT -- MISTER SUTTON
AS AS REYES.
I GUESS THE BOTTOM LINE IS YES
WE WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION --
YOU KNOW MANY OTHER MEMBERS THIS
IS AN UNNATURAL FOR THEM YOU'RE
DOING IT BUT THEY DO RAISE
ISSUES AT THE RESTAURANT SCENE
IN CALIFORNIA.
IS QUITE.
AND SO -- THEY HAVE -- BOWS
UNLESS AMENDED SO.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO TRYING.
TO CENTURY OR NAY WITH THE GOALS
OF ORGANIC SO. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE AND ON GOING PROCESS.
I THINK THAT THE INTENT OF THE
THE LETTER THAT WAS SUBMITTED BY
MISTER SUTTON.
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
THE SPONSOR AND THE AUTHOR.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO RUN THE
TRAPS ON THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
IS EITHER ANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES?
BUT THAT REALLY THEY'LL GOAL WAS
TO HAVE THE SUPPLY TO THE
BUSINESSES THAT ALREADY SUBJECT.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX AND THREE
FORTY ONE IT DOESN'T NOT
INTENDED TO TOUCH THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE BUSINESSES BETTER
REGULATIONS BEING DEVELOPER NOW.
I'M AND ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE
EXISTING EXEMPTIONS IN EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SIX AND THREE FORTY ONE
WE DID INTEND TO APPLY HERE.
SO WE'RE HAVING ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WE DON'T DISAGREE.
IN SPIRIT WITH THAT RESTAURANTS
ASSOCIATIONS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY YEAH.
HOUSE DID YOU WANNA ASK
QUESTIONS.
I HAD A QUESTION ON THE BACK OF
THE HOUSE NOT THE FRIEND PASSED
ON THE COMMERCIAL.
WE ALL THEM FULL SERVICE
RESTAURANTS.
SOME OF THOSE FULL SERVICE
RESTAURANTS ARE STILL REQUIRED
TO DO ORGANIC.
SORTING RIGHT THE BACK IN THE
BACK OF HOUSE OKAY.
THIS MIGHT BE A THIRD FROM THE
HOW OLD IS IS THE ONES THAT NOT
TO SIT DOWN REST. ONE THREE TO
GET UP AND GO. TO HAVE THOSE
SAME TYPE OF EFFORT YOU HAVE IN
THE BACK.
THERE ARE YOU ALREADY HAVE A ON
BACK ANYWAY.
MY WITH BUT OKAY COME OUT AND
SERVICE AND SO THE NOTION IS IT
IT'S ALREADY THERE THIS IS.
AWESOME.
AND IF THE OBJECTION I HAVEN'T
SEEN THE THE LETTER OF CAPTION
IT'S STRICTLY FOR THE FROM THE
HOUSE AFTER THE BACK OF HOUSE.
THAT IS TO SENATOR AND AND THE
THE CRUX OF THE OBJECTION IS
MORE CAN WE ALIGN WITH WHAT'S
BEING DONE IT CARRY CYCLE RIGHT
NOW AND THE OTHER ISSUE THAT
DOES COME UP.
THAT I THINK WE CAN ALL RELATE
TO IS THAT YOU KNOW THERE ARE
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT EVEN
UNDER EXISTING LAWS AND
REGULATIONS DON'T HAVE THESE
ORGANIC SERVICES.
AND IN THE EXISTING REGULATIONS
THERE SOME FLEXIBILITY THAT
WE'RE NOT.
JUST BECAUSE THE LANDLORD WON'T
LET US DO IT WERE BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT THE ACTUAL SERVICE.
SO A LOT OF THIS IS JUST TRYING
TO GET.
THAT DRESS PRESS THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT ISSUE WE DO KNOW
THERE ARE SOME AREAS ESPECIALLY
RURAL AREAS.
THAT THERE IS A PROCESS FOR YOU
CAN BUY [inaudible]
FOR AN EXEMPTION [inaudible]
SO.
WE'D BE WILLING TO HAVE THAT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT I THINK.
WE WE CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE THIS
THIS -- THIS CONTAIN DISCUSSION
WE DON'T WANT TO YOU KNOW.
ULTIMATELY.
I WANT TO MARRY THAT
[inaudible]
EXISTING REGULATORY.
PROCESS IN PLACE WITH WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO I THINK.
I THINK EVERYONE IS CAN
GENERALLY.
CONCORD WITH.
BROAD GOALS THE MATTER.
OF COHERENCE AND IN COORDINATION
[inaudible]
SO.
I DO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUED DIALOGUE WITH OUR WITH
OUR FOLKS FROM THE THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY.
OKAY I'M ON THE OTHER QUESTIONS
SPOTS CONCERNS.
BY THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS
MOVEMENT BY.
TERRA CASKEY IF YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE HOWEVER.
I THANK YOU FOR THAT THE
DIALOGUE I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE IT FRANKLY
SIMPLE EVERYBODY CAN.
VISUALIZE BUT THIS WILL%
CERTAINLY HELP US GET TO OUR
RECYCLING GOALS IN CALIFORNIA
HAS TO DRIVE THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU EVERYBODY.
I EXAMPLES CARL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB EIGHT TWENTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED.
ALLEN HI ALLEN I NO HILL
[inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STERN I NO NO I CASKEY.
I OKAY SO WE'LL LEAVE THAT.
ROLL OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS AND
ON IN AND DONE WE SEE CENTER FOR
MEN'S IS BACK UP FOR SURE YOU'RE
[inaudible]
SINCE.
SO EVERY MINUTES YOU'RE
PRESENTING AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
WHICH HAS TO DO WITH RECYCLED
WATER.
YOU MAY RECEIVE WHEN THE WHEN
READY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THERE BRING YOU -- BILL
THAT'S RECEIVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO NO VOTES.
WE HAVE UP THE COURAGE A LOT OF
OUR CITIES TO PIPE FOR NON
POTABLE REUSE.
RECYCLED WATER SO THIS IS YOUR
PURPLE PIPED WATER BUT BECAUSE
THE UP THE REGULATIONS THAT
GOVERN THAT WATER HASN'T BEEN
UPDATED IN ALMOST TWENTY YEARS.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR A LOT OF
MUNICIPALITIES AND FOUR BUILDING
OWNERS TO FULLY -- ENJOY THE
BENEFITS THAT HAVING THAT NON
POTABLE WATER WHO WOULD INCLUDE --
AND I AM GOING TO APOLOGIZE
RIGHT NOW FOR THIS PARAGRAPH AND
THEN YOU CAN DECIDE IF YOU WANT
TO HEAR MORE LIKE THIS.
AB -- ELEVEN EIGHTY REQUIRES
THAT THE BACK FLOW REGULATIONS
IN TITLE SEVENTEEN INCLUDE THE
USE OF CHANGEOVER DEVICE OR
SWIVEL L. THAT CONFORMS TO
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS THAT'S JUST
TO GIVE YOU A TASTE OF HELL
WONKY IN TECHNICAL THIS BILL
ACTUALLY IS -- BUT WE DO BELIEVE
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM A LOT OF
OUR AGENCIES FROM A LOT OF OUR
BUILDERS THAT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT OF THESE REGULATIONS --
GET UPDATED SO THEY CAN REALLY
USE THOUGH THE RECYCLED WATER.
WITH THAT I HAVE LARA LOS SO
WITH ME TODAY -- ARE SORRY ABOUT
THE LOSS SO.
I LOOK AT YOU AND I SEE YOU'RE
MY MOTHER -- REPRESENTING --
WAIT RE USE.
THIS IS BETH -- ALSO FROM WATER
CALIFORNIA THAT'S FINE.
TAKE MY MOM EVERYDAY.
UP WITH WATER USE CALIFORNIA AS
YOU SOME A MEMBER SAID --
REGULATIONS JUST NEED TO GET
UPDATED SO WE ARE.
USING EVERY PIECE OF TECHNOLOGY
POSSIBLE AND AND GETTING
EVERYTHING WE CAN RE USE EVERY
DROP AT EVERY POINT IN BUILDINGS
IN PARKS AND LIBRARIES -- AND
AND USING ALL WATER POSSIBLE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IT'S A VERY TECHNICAL
BILL THANK YOU [inaudible]
Q..
HI FOLKS WANT TO WIN IN SUPPORT.
RENDON ASSOCIATE OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
ALL WITH THE ASSOCIATION
PROPERTY WATER AGENCIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I KNOW WITH THE SENATE OUR WATER
VALUE.
IN MORNING ROSY THOMPSON
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
SEVEN CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
POLICIES FOR NOT GETTING OUR
LETTER IN BUT WE'LL GET THAT IN
CIVIC IF SOMEONE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE PLUGINS OFFICE HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE LARGE
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT AND THE
TOWN OF WINDSOR IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
I ANYONE WHO ANSWERS CONCERNS
OPPOSITION THE BILL.
I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ANY
RESTAURANT.
OKAY THE ITEMS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS --
THOUGHTS IDEAS.
UNDER SKINNER AND THE BEST.
AS I CENTER STONE OKAY ALRIGHT
ARE YOU RIGHT WILL LISTENERS
KNOW AS LONG AS IT'S NOT -- I
WILL WILL.
IT HAS BEEN MOVED BUT WE DO HAVE
A QUESTION FROM OUR OUR FRIEND
CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER THANKS RIVAS
FOR WE'VE BEEN OPEN FOR THIS
KIND OF MEASURE FOR AWHILE NOW
I'M JUST WONDERING ABOUT
ENFORCEMENT AND HOW.
IT CAN ACTUALLY.
BE SURE THERE'S GONNA BE
CONFORMITY I THINK WE WE HAVE
CHALLENGES.
THROUGHOUT.
OUR WATER. TWENTY FOUR FRANKLY
FOR JUST A GENERAL LACK OF
IMPLEMENTATION ENFORCEMENT HERE
SO.
YOU ALL SEE MAYBE IT WORRIES I
MEAN IS ARE WE ACT ARE WE
ACTUALLY GONNA DO THIS ARE WE
JUST GONNA TELL THE CONTRACTORS
TO DO THIS.
WE WE SEE SORT OF AT TIMES THE
GAPS.
MAY BE SO BOLD IN TERMS OF HOW
OFTEN PEOPLE ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT --
THESE MEASURES WHEN THEY GO TO
CONSTRUCTION.
I AM AND ONE OF THE BILL IS JUST
TO GET THE REGULATIONS UPDATED
SENATE THIS CAN GO FORWARD -- WE
ARE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ON ON
PROMOTING THIS TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY IN AND USE -- IN THE
FUTURE BUT THIS IS JUST I MEAN.
WHAT WENT INTO THE SPECIFICS
RIGHT NOW IF YOU WANTED WILL
COME A BUILDING YOU HAVE TO USE?
IT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO
CROSS CONNECTION AND THE THE
WHICH UNDERSTANDABLE BUT THE
CURRENT STANDARD IS USING THIS
VERY EXPENSIVE HERE GAP -- AND
NOW WE'VE MOVED AWAY FROM WEEK
WE HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO USE A
SWIVEL L. AND SO THIS IS JUST
SAYING OKAY WATER BOARD.
LET'S LET'S GIVE YOU THAT SO
THAT WE CAN USE THAT DEVICE TO
SWITCH OVER FROM PORTABLE THE
NON POTABLE.
SO WE THINK THAT WITH THESE
REGULATIONS IN PLACE THAT IT'LL
JUST MAKE IT EASIER AND CHEAPER.
TO DO IT IN THE SAFE AND
EFFICIENT MANNER [inaudible]
THANKS.
I'M SO SORRY I'M SO SORRY ONCE
AGAIN [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANKS HEARING KERRY
[inaudible]
OKAY I SO ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
SPOTS.
OKAY WELL LET'S SON.
LETS BUT THE AUTHOR.
THE QUESTIONS AND THE INTEREST
IN THIS -- AGAIN IT'S NOT
RECEIVED ANY OPPOSITION.
AND WE THINK IT'S TIME TO
SPECULATION.
THE TICKET BEFORE.
ITEM NUMBER SIX A. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
ALLEN HI ALLEN I I STILL.
WELL I SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN AYE STONE.
STONE I ASKING.
HI OKAY SO THAT BILLS UNANIMOUS
SON PASS OUT GRADUATION THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH A REALLY TODAY.
SIGN OVER OKAY SO WHY DON'T WE
YEAH LET'S TAKE A MOMENT TO RUN
TO BE OPEN AND OVERALL.
SO.
IS THAT THE CONSENT.
I MEAN.
LET'S FIRST -- LET'S FIRST TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. TO THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN ADDED ON YET TO
SECRETARY PEOPLE CAME CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS NUMBER. THREE
FOUR SEVEN NINE TEN AND TWELVE
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN RIGHT STERN
AYE OKAY CELESTINA MISSILE
CLOSER ON THAT.
SEVEN ZERO RIGHT NOW IS ARE
GOING TO THE ITEMS THAT WE HAVE --
ORDER FOR TODAY I NUMBER ONE
THIS IS AB TWO NINETY THREE
EDUARDO GARCIA.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB.
TWO NINETY THREE CHAIR VOTING I
I STRUGGLING EYES SIX ZERO
SKINNER.
YEAH ITEM NUMBER.
ONE SKINNER I SEVEN ZERO CLOSER
ALL THE NEXT THE OVERNIGHT THE
BILL THIS IS A I AM TO AB.
THREE NINETY FOUR I AND NUMBER
TWO AB THREE NINETY FOUR CHAIR
VOTING I BY STRUGGLING I FOUR
ZERO SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
THAT'S FOUR ZERO CALL THE ROLL
ON THAT.
OUR NEXT ONE IS THE MCCARTY BILL
WE JUST HEARD ABOUT AND
RECYCLING BINS AND THIS IS A ABA.
TWENTY SEVEN AND NUMBER FIVE AB
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN CHAIR VOTING
AYE AYE SIR VOTING NO KILL
[inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
SKINNER I AS FIVE TO TO WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
BUDGET.
TO CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT.
NEXT ONE IS THIS PRETTY WELL WE
JUST HEARD THAT THAT'S CLOSE SO
THAT WE HAVE -- RIVAS IS BILL
THIS IS ITEM EIGHT AB.
TWELVE FIFTY TWO IN VERMONT A
SMALL GRANT PROGRAM.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWELVE
FIFTY TWO CHAIR VOTING I BY
SERVING I FOUR ZERO SKINNER.
AB TWELVE FIFTY TWO ITEM.
NUMBER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN AYE STONE.
STONE I OKAY WILL CLOSE RUNNERS
UNANIMOUS SEVEN ZERO FINALLY.
ANOTHER RIVAS SPELL -- OPR THIS
IS SAID TO BE.
SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN A. B. SIXTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT GERMANY I I STRUGGLING NOW.
THREE IS TO SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN I ARE
THE TWO THAT IS OUT OKAY.
HI MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES OUR
VOTES I DO WANNA JUST FOR THOSE
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE AT THE
BEGINNING I DO WANT TO ONCE
AGAIN THINK OUR GOOD FRIEND
DAVID GARCIA WHOSE WORK ON OUR
STAFF -- FOR FOR QUITE SOMETIME
NOW IS IS JUST A FANTASTIC STAFF
HE'S GOING OVER TO THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. TO WORK ON
LEGISLATORS.
I LITERALLY ON FRIDAY I THINK
HIS LAST THEIR THIS IS TOMORROW
AND YOU.
HE'S GOT SIXTEEN HOURS OF OF
FREEDOM.
AND THEN IS GOING STRAIGHT OVER
THE AIRPORT BUT WE WE DO WE
REALLY DO THANK HIM FOR HIS
SERVICES COMMITTEE AND AND
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING YOU'VE
DONE WITH US SO THANK YOU.
AND I LOOK FOR TO SEE YOU ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
ORIEL COMMON YES PLEASE. FOR
THOSE WHO MAY -- WONDER THE
VALUE OF OUR SCIENCE HELLO
PROGRAM [inaudible]
YES DAVID.
THE REASON IS IN THE CAPITALIST
DESPITE THAT WHAT WITH.
YEAH GO SCIENCE.
THERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU DAVID.
WITH THAT THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED TO PROCEED EVERYONE'S
INCLUSION FIGURE